alors aujourd'hui on va
on va parler de climat qui connaît la
thrombine du type qui est à droite la
fois plus non oui une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de personnes qui sait ce qu'il
faisait à ce moment là oui donc très
bien et son nom est bond fabius
absolument ancien premier ministre de la
france
alors monsieur laurent fabius en
décembre 2015
abba tel un commissaire priseur son
marteau sur le pupitre et déclare
accepter ou approuver l'accord de paris
qui dit que les pays de la planète vont
faire leurs meilleurs efforts pour que
l'élévation de température reste bien en
dessous de deux degrés donc si cet
accord est effectivement avait une
portée effective pratique et bien vous
pourrez remplacer secours par une grande
récréation vous entre le problème est
réglé donc c'est pas la peine de nous en
kit idéaux vous expliquant de quoi il
retourne avec le problème ce problème
est réglé
alors malheureusement il va quand même
falloir deux heures et demie pour vous
expliquer que le problème est très très
loin d'être réglé et que il y a encore
un petit peu de chemin entre la coupe et
les lèvres
vous avez ici une courbe de la
concentration atmosphérique en co2
exprimées en millionième donc on exprime
la concentration atmosphérique en co2 en
général je vais revenir longuement sur
ce que c'est que le co2 et d'où il sort
etc mais qui est exprimé en partie par
volume c'est à dire la fraction molaires
de l'atmosphère qui est composé d'un
volume qui composait de co2 cd
millionième donc quand vous avez sur ce
graphique 300 ppm 3 100 millionième ça
vous fait 0 point 0 3% c'est aussi comme
ça que vous pouvez regarder et au lieu
de graduer en fonction des années
donc cette année correspond à 1995 et
cette année correspond à 2017
j'ai gradué en fonction du numéro de la
réunion annuelle
de la conférence des parties de la
convention climat vous savez la
convention climat j'y reviendrai aussi
pendant ce court est le suivant c'est
l'accord onusien que tous les pays de la
planète ont signé plus ratifié en disant
qu'on allait s'occuper de vous c'est à
dire des générations futures puisque ça
a été signé en 1992 et je pense que en
1992 il n'y avait pas grand monde dans
cette salle qui était déjà né donc les
générations futures c'est vous et donc
dans ce papier on a dit qu'on allait
s'occuper des générations futures
alors ça c'est signé en 1992 et ratifiée
en 1995 et en 1995 un grand succès
puisque la convention climat qui dit
qu'on va s'occuper de vous entre en
vigueur et il y à la première réunion
annuelle de la conférence des parties
c'est à dire lorsqu'on appelle la
conférence des parties c'est pas
débouché qui se réunissent pour discuter
des bons morceaux du boeuf non la
conférence des parties c'est la réunion
annuelle des parties à la convention
parce que dans le jargon onusien un pays
qui signent ou qu'ils ratifient une
convention s'appelle une partie voilà
donc les parties à la convention en fait
c'est les pays où les entités puisque
l'union européenne et ratifie catr qui
en ont ratifié la convention dont cannes
et un de la vie de cette convention qui
entre en vigueur 1995 en succès
évidemment 1997 c'est l'année du
protocole de kyoto qui est j'y
reviendrai pas en détail qui est une
annexe à la convention climat dans
laquelle on dit ben voilà il ya un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde qui
vont prendre des engagements quantitatif
de réductions dont la france donc la
france a dit les réductions qui viennent
de chez moi vont baisser de 5% entre
telle année et l année et un certain
nombre d'autres pays ont pris exactement
le même genre dont quelques uns de leurs
ouvriers l'effet que ça a eu sur la
concentration atmosphérique par la suite
arrive copenhague qualifié d' énorme
échec bon harris paris qualifié d'
énorme succès on verra donc cette petite
entrée en matière est là pour vous
montrer que malheureusement et on le
verra sur certains certain nombre
d'autres courbes que je vais vous
montrer
jusqu'à maintenant la quantité de bruits
faits sur le changement climatique est
un paramètre qui n'a pas d' influence
sur ce qui se passe vraiment d'accord
donc il ya deux processus décorrélée
dans le monde sait ce qui se passe
vraiment au niveau des émissions et des
processus climatiques qui en découlent
et la quantité de gens qui disent qu'il
faudrait faire quelque chose voilà ces
deux processus pour le moment totalement
distincts malheureusement on va parler
de climat alors parlant de climat
je vais insister même pour les cervelles
bien fait que vous êtes
nous allons parler de quelque chose qui
est inaccessible à vos sens
d'accord vous avez beau être de très
brillant élève ingénieur sélectionné
pour entrer dans une école très
difficile d'accès vous restez des
animaux comme moi et donc vous faites
confiance à vos sens parce que l'espèce
humaine est une espèce qui fait
confiance à ses sens encore donc on date
d'une époque où c'était nos sens qui
nous disait qu'il fallait courir pour
échapper au tigre à dents de sabre qu'il
pensait que d'affaires sont quatre
heures avec nous et donc on sait ce que
c'est que les choses que nos sens nous
indique dans notre environnement
immédiat
alors en ce qui concerne les paramètres
climatiques ce que nos sens à vous
indiquer dans notre environnement
immédiat c'est la température qui fait
tout de suite là où on est
éventuellement les précipitations qui a
tout de suite là où on est la luminosité
qui a tout de suite là où on est là
début lose it et c'est à dire les nuages
qui a tout de suite là où on est le vent
qui a tout de suite la monnaie etc
ces paramètres l'a apprécié de façon
locale et instantanée en science ça
conduit à ce qu'on appelle la météo donc
la météo c'est l'évolution instantanée
et local ou dans un avenir très proche
de choses qui parle à nos sens c'est à
dire les conditions qui va faire ici ce
matin pour savoir si je mettais un
manteau ou pas j'ai regardé la météo
qu'il allait faire à paris et je me
fiche comme de l'an 40 de savoir quelle
est la météo aujourd'hui à buno crs pour
prendre le mouvement voilà m'intéresse
pas tout ce qui m'intéresse pour savoir
si je mets un manteau ou pas c'est la
météo qui va faire apparaît alors le
climat a contrario dont on va parler
maintenant est quelque chose qui est
inaccessible à vos sens en tout cas de
façon directe il de façon indirecte mais
il était accessible de façon directe
parce que quand on parle de climat
on va parler de moyenne or une moyenne
vous le savez comme moi c'est une
construction intellectuelle
d'accord c'est une série ou une
intégrale donc c'est pas un truc que
vous observez dans la nature
c'est une construction intellectuelle
une moyenne or c'est cette construction
intellectuelle qui va permettre de
comprendre si oui ou non on est en train
de dériver hors norme par rapport à
quelque chose qui est notre
environnement habituel alors vous voyez
quand même des manifestations indirecte
du climat dans le monde qui nous entoure
par exemple dans les manifestations en
direct et à la végétation manifestement
la végétation qui a au groenland y en a
pas beaucoup
la végétation qui a en afrique et la
végétation qu'il ya sur le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen sont pas les mêmes
c'est parce que le climat n'est pas le
même donc des manifestations indirecte
du climat vous envoyer mais des
manifestations direct c'est à dire avoir
une approche et une moyenne par ses sens
on n'y arrive pas alors il ya une
confusion les deux mon général
la confusion vient de ce que dans un cas
comme dans l'autre on manipule les mêmes
critères
c'est à dire que c'est les mêmes
variables on manipule mais dans un cas
on va regarder des valeurs instant pas
des locales et dans l'autre cas on va
regarder des moyennes spatiale ou
temporelle ou les deux et les variations
régulière de ses moyennes par exemple la
variation saisonnière fait partie du
climat vous avez des variations
saisonnières qui concerne la température
ça c'est des moyennes latitudes qui
concerne éventuellement le fait qu'ils
aient du soleil ça c'est l'épaule ou qui
concerne le fait qu'ils aient beaucoup
de pluie au peu de pluie ça c'est plutôt
les régions équatoriales
donc vous avez des pas des variations
saisonnières qui sont pas toujours les
mêmes
où que vous alliez alors je vais me
taper sur mes ennemis préférés à savoir
les journalistes je vais vous donnez là
un exemple de quelque chose qui s'est
produit il ya quelques années de quelque
chose qui s'est produit il ya quelques
années que j'avais trouvé intéressant il
y avait eu un moment un article dans le
journal comme il ya de temps en temps
avec des gens qui veulent se rendre
intéressant en disant qu'on va voir s'il
peut pas y avoir de réchauffement
climatique parce que la planète est en
ce moment ça se réchauffe pas il fait
froid
alors voilà un jour oui se trouve que le
hasard afin qu' il ya eu des anomalies
négative c'est-à-dire des températures
plus fraîches que la moyenne dans tout
un tas d'endroits fortement peuplées
vous voyez un bout du drop ou des états
unis à bout du japon etc
or il se trouve que là où il ya des
hommes il ya des agences de presse et il
ya des gens pour aurait des communiqués
de presse
donc il ya des tas de gens qui disent
regarder là où je suis là aujourd'hui là
tout de suite il fait froid
sauf que au même moment ni les pingouins
ni les dauphins au milieu de
l'atlantique ni tous ces gens là n'ont
pu dire ah mais vous savez chez nous en
ce moment et c'est beaucoup plus chaud
que la moyenne
donc si vous faites vraiment une moyenne
c'est-à-dire avec la wii c'est plus
franc et là où il fait plus chaud il n'y
a pas de problème la moyenne de
l'ensemble de la surface planétaire est
bien au dessus de sa valeur de référence
voilà donc il ya et ça ça continue de
temps en temps plus - c'est c'est plus
rare maintenant mais enfin il continue à
y avoir quelques personnes qui jouent à
ce genre de petits jeux
c'est assez facile encore une fois en
faisant la confusion entre une valeur
instantanée une moyenne ça ne tient qu'à
ça et c'est très facile encore une fois
d'abuser les gens qui sont pas familiers
du sujet parce que c'est les mêmes
paramètres et parce que nos sens ne nous
dise pas ce que c'est qu'une moyenne
il ya un autre travers qui est assez
classique il faut que je change l'année
tous les ans mais bon c'est toujours le
même principe qui est assez classique
quand on s'intéresse à ce sujet là c'est
de mal interpréter une série 1
donc là je pourrais dire que l'effet de
ce processus c'est le relèvement des
températures je pourrais aussi dire que
c'est la baisse du nombre de bateaux de
pirates parce que de fait les sous
vêtements ont diminué en même temps que
le nombre de bateaux de pirates a baissé
donc c'est très facile de faire une
mauvaise interprétation de ce qu'on est
en train d'observer tant qu'on n'a pas
compris les processus
donc il faut il faut être voilà du coup
c'est très facile d'avoir une mauvaise
conclusion le climat ces dons des
valeurs moyennes géographique et enfin
spatiale et temporelle
mais même ces moyennes sont amenés à
changer en fait le climat de la terre
depuis que la terre existe n'a jamais
été stable sur des périodes géologiques
dans la période géologique on s'en fiche
un peu quand on est un homme ou une
femme parce que votre espérance de vie
si tout va bien une l'ordre de grandeur
du siècle même si tout va mal de
quelques décennies enfin je vous le
souhaite donc ce qui se passe sur
quelques millions d'années
mais la terre est passé par des époques
très très contrastée en ce qui concerne
son climat par exemple il ya eu une
époque où il y avait pas d'oxygène dans
l'atmosphère terrestre ou la postière
terrestre était composé essentiellement
de co2 puis de méthane et d'azoté
il ya eu des époques où la terre était
probablement quasiment totalement en
glace et calotte qui couvrait la
quasi-totalité de la terre il ya eu une
époque où il n'y avait pas deux
continents et enfin bon bref la terre et
passer par des étapes extrêmement variés
et si on regarde les quelques derniers
millions d'années c'est-à-dire l'ère
quaternaire
à ce moment là il ya eu même à ce moment
là des grandes oscillations climatiques
qui sont les glaciations déglaciation
donc le climat n'est pas du tout rester
stables si on se place à des échelles de
temps qu'ils sont le million d'années au
moins
on a un premier facteur de forçage qui
s'appelle le forçage astronomiques alors
le forçage astronomique vient du fait
que le système solaire c'est un ménage à
10 est pas un ménage à deux et donc la
terre subit l'attraction des grosses
planètes du système solaire
donc on n'est pas dans une ellipse
parfaite régulière au cours du temps qui
est celle que vous savez calculé j'ai
plus ou en géométrie avec juste deux
corps on est dans un système à dix corps
encore moins bien en tout cas c'est pas
régulier donc il ya des variations de
l'orbité je vais dire juste après et ça
ça peut déformer le système climatique
sur des échelles de temps qui sont de
l'ordre de la centaine de milliers
d'années les continents ne sont pas
toujours là où ils sont nés une dérive
comme vous savez des continents et en
fonction de l'endroit où un continent et
bien la réflexion de la lumière solaire
est plus ou moins importante
par exemple quand vous avez des
continents qui se rapproche des pôles
vous pouvez avoir des calottes
permanente qui apparaissent typiquement
le groenland est à ce moment vous créez
une surface très réfléchissante beaucoup
plus réfléchissantes que l'océanic qui
se trouvait là avant l'installation de
la calotte antarctique sur le pôle sud
il ya quelques dizaines de millions
d'années or j'ai lu 36,15 larmes enfin
dans de grandes heures elle-même et bien
a refroidi le climat planétaire de
quelques degrés à cause de la création
de ce grand miroir qui évacuent une
partie du rayonnement solaire sans
qu'ils aient le temps de chauffer le sol
après vous avez des oscillations interne
au compartiment fluide de l'atmosphère
et notamment des processus qui sont
liées à la circulation océanique à large
échelle qui peuvent changer le climat
sur des périodes de temps qui vont du
siècle au millénaire est évidemment vous
avez la dynamique interne de
l'atmosphère mais ça ça change le climat
sur des durées qui sont très très courte
et puis maintenant vous avez nous tout
en bas à la cause anthropique donc
cocorico nous sommes devenus un agent
climatique nous sommes devenus un agent
qui force le système climatique
quand vous faites de la bto donc j'y
reviens là seul le seul compartiment qui
réagit à l'échelle de la journée c'est
l'atmosphère donc vous faites un bon
modèle d'atmosphère donc vous prenez vos
copains pour vous parce que vous savez
pas fermer vos copains de super héros x
à faire et vous les envoyer à météo
france ou leur demander de faire un
modèle de climat et il vous prévoit
correctement la météo d'accord par
contre si vous voulez regarder comment
évolue le système à l'échelle du siècle
ce dont on va parler maintenant ça
suffit plus de faire un bon modèle
atmosphérique
ça ne suffit pas il faut savoir
modéliser l'évolution à ces échelles de
temps d'autres compartiments de la
planète et en particulier de l'océan et
en particulier de l'océan l'océan c'est
le compartiment fluide qui pilotent
l'évolution du système climatique à
l'échelle du siècle beaucoup plus que
l'atmosphère
donc si vous voulez faire un bon modèle
météo vous lever le nez si vous voulez
faire un bon modèle de climat au
contraire vous baissez la tête à des
échelles de temps encore plus longue
donc comme je le disais c'est les
paramètres astronomiques qui domine
alors ces paramètres astronomiques
quelles sont leurs quelles sont leurs
variations
la première c'est que à cause donc de
l'attraction des grosses planètes du
système solaire vous avez trois
paramètres qui vont varier au cours du
temps la première c'est que bon la terre
fait pas une ellipse exact puisque ça se
déforme et enfin c'est une quasi
ellipses dont l'excentricité et plus ou
moins grande avec une quasi périodicité
de cent mille ans d'accord ça c'est une
première variation qui est un duo
introduite par là
l'attraction des des grosses planètes la
deuxième variations qui est introduite
par les grosses planètes c'est que vous
avez la kz2 rotation de la terre qui est
plus ou moins inclinés sur le plan de
l'orbité
alors vous comprenez que si l' axe de
rotation de la terre était totalement
perpendiculaire au plan de l'orbité est
ce qu'on aurait des saisons non on
n'arrête pas de saison d'accord parce
que l'inclinaison solaire serait
toujours là même toute l'année donc la
quantité de chaleur récupérée a eu
l'attitude données seraient toujours là
même toute l'année soit dit en passant
climat vient du mot grec climat car lim
à qui veut dire inclinaison par contre
quand vous avez une inclinaison
extrêmement prononcée
et bien selon la période de l'année où
vous êtes vous avez la tête au chaud ou
les fesses au froid enfin il inverse et
donc vous avez un très gros contraste
entre les saisons d'accord donc plus lax
est incliné sur le plan de l'orbité est
plus fin plus il se rapproche du plan de
l'orbité on va dire et plus vous avez un
contraste important entre les saisons et
en particulier à ce moment là vous
pouvez avoir des étés plus chauds et des
hivers plus froids quand vous rapprocher
des moyennes latitudes et enfin la
dernière chose qui se passe c'est que
vous avez lax comme une toupie l'axé de
rotation de la terre qui tourne autour
de la perpendiculaire au plan de
l'orbité
ce qui veut dire que comme vous avez un
apogée et à péri g eh bien vous montrer
alternativement la tête ou les fesses
c'est à dire l'hémisphère nord et
l'hémisphère sud au plus près au plus
loin du soleil donc avec une quasi
périodicité de vingt mille ans vous avez
plutôt l'hémisphère nord quand vous êtes
au plus près du soleil qui est qui qui
regarde le soleil ou plutôt l'hémisphère
sud a encore soit l'un soit l'autre et
ça ça change avec une quasi périodicité
de 20 millions quand vous mettez tout ça
boutabout vous avez notamment quelque
chose qui varie de manière forte
c'est l'insolation à 65° north of
empires d'insolation à 61,2 alors
presque on s'intéresse tout d'un coup là
alors pourquoi parce que c'est la zone
très sensible qui conditionne les
entrées en glaciation ou les sorties
de glaciation pendant l'ère quaternaire
parce que c'est un endroit où avec les
variations de ses paramètres
astronomiques vous pouvez avoir une
variation très importante de
l'insolation qui est reçu en particulier
en été plus lax se redresse et plus la
quantité plus moyens contraste entre les
saisons et donc à ce moment l'été est
proportionnellement moins chaud ce
n'était est proportionnellement moins
chaud et quand vous êtes suffisamment
près des pôles pour qui neige quand même
l'hiver à ce moment vous avez la neige
qui n'a plus envie de beaucoup font dans
l'été la neige se met à s'accumuler
année après année vous entrez en
glaciation d'accord donc en fait une des
conditions de l'entrée en classe iations
c'est que l' axe se redresse sur le plan
de l'orbité et corrélativement quand ils
s'inclinent celle inverse vous avez des
étés très chauds ça se met à fondre donc
vous avez ici des variations de
l'association qui font avec les entrées
et les sorties de la dernière glaciation
qui sont illustrés ici alors dans tout
se sait et paramètres il y en a un qui
aujourd'hui est devenu le paramètre
dominant ce alors que m'interrompt 30
secondes pour retrouver la petite
animation qui va bien voilà ici vous
avez une petite animation faite par les
seules personnes sérieuses qui compte
dans ce monde c'est à dire les
producteurs de champagne
en plus c'est vrai on fait cette petite
animation en 2002 pour la conférence qui
essaye d'expliquer en quoi consiste la
mécanique on va dire la dynamique de
l'effet de serre qui est un des
processus qui sont qui est à l'oeuvre
dans en ce qui concerne la formation du
climat alors vous avez ici un une
illustration simplifiée de la surface
terrestre constitué de sol émerger et
d'eau d'océan et de l'apport énergétique
qui permet à la machine climatique de
fonctionner c'est à dire de l'énergie
solaire de la machine climatique elle
est comme toutes les machines au monde
elle est soumise à la première loi de la
thermodynamique temps pour qu'elle fasse
quelque chose il faut de l'énergie et
cette énergie est essentiellement a mené
par le rayonnement solaire
alors ce rayonnement solaire quand il
arrive à la surface de l'atmosphère
vous en avez en gros un tiers qui est
réfléchie vers l'espace par tout ce qui
est brillant en vue de l'espace
donc si vous regardez une photo
satellite de la terre
avait deux types de surfaces qui sont
particulièrement brillante qui sont la
neige ça vous allez trouver et puis des
déserts so lu ment donc vous avez la
neige et les déserts qui sont
particulièrement réfléchissant ça ça
vous évacuez à peu près un tiers de
l'énergie solaire incidente
les deux tiers restants puisqu'ils sont
pas réfléchies c'est qu'ils sont
absorbés et ils vont être notamment
absorbé par le sol alors le sol comme
tout
j'ai envie de dire comme comme dans tout
système énergétique va récupérer de
l'énergie qui est celle qui l'absorbent
sous forme de rayonnement lumineux
enfin de rayonnement électromagnétique
pour être plus précis parce que va dire
que 50% du rayonnement solaire c'est la
prof prochain il dirait qu'il ya que 40%
visible et 10% d'ultraviolets donc le
sol absorbant l'énergie solaire va
chercher à se mettre à l'équilibré
énergétique
lui aussi est le sol à trois manières de
se mettre à l'équilibré énergétique
c'est-à-dire de restituer en régime
stationnaire l'énergie que lui a fourni
le soleil la première manière qu'il a
assez de la chaleur de contact dont vous
êtes au dessus d'un seul show vous
mettez de l'air au dessus
la chaleur sur transfère directement par
contact c'est une première manière dont
le sol restitue l'énergie une deuxième
manière dont le sol restitue l'énergie
alors c'est pas très bien représentés
mais vous le voyez quand même là avec
cette espèce de petit truc flashy bleus
là c'est la chaleur latente de l'eau
évaporation condensation donc quand vous
chauffez le sol qui se trouve être aux
deux tiers de l'eau parce que les deux
tiers de la planète sont couverts d'eau
et bien vous allez évaporé de l'eau et
là vous avez de la chaleur latente qui
est utilisé pour l'évaporation restituer
dans l'atmosphère et vous allez avoir un
troisième mode de restitution de la de
l'énergie qui est que le sol va rayonner
de l'infrarouge ce que vous rappeler que
tout corps au studio qu'elle vit une
période quelque chose alors le soleil
qui en surface et assimile kelvin
inspectent dans lequel il ya beaucoup de
visible beaucoup d'infrarouge proche un
peu d'ultraviolets la terre qui est en
moyenne à 300 kelvin en ordre de
grandeur enfin un peu plus 310 un
spectre qui est
beaucoup plus long d'accord c'est
beaucoup se déplacer vers des longueurs
d'onde qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes
et dans ces longueurs d'onde plus
importante il ya essentiellement ce
qu'on appelle de l'infrarouge lointain
qui est soit dit en passant à peu près
le même rayonnement infrarouge que celui
que vous émettez vous et qui vous permet
d'être vu avec une caméra infrarouge ou
qui permet de regarder les infrarouges
qui s'échappe de la passoire thermique
dans laquelle vous habitez si c'est le
cas tout ça c'est dans les même longueur
d'onde et il se trouve que l'atmosphère
qui est parfaitement transparente au
rayonnement solaire incident à
l'exception de caisse qui passe pas à
travers l'atmosphère des ultras murray
qui sont interceptés par une espèce
chimiques que vous trouvez dans la
stratosphère qui s'appelle l'ozone est
bien à l'exception de cette interception
là l'essentiel du rayonnement solaire
passe à travers l'atmosphère sans
encombre alors que le rayonnement rémy
par la planète et il s'agit bien de rêve
de rémy pas réfléchi comme je le trouve
parfois dans quelques copies et bien se
sait de l'infrarouge lointain pour le
pour lesquels pardon l'atmosphère va
comporter des espèces qui sont très
fortement au pack assez infrarouge est
très fortement au parc ça veut dire
qu'il dispose de ré d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge lointain est en fait à gaz
à effet de serre c'est ça sa définition
c'est à gaz qui possèdent des raies
d'absorption dans l'infrarouge lointain
émis par la planète comme l'atmosphère
et marche ça marche est essentiellement
donc opaque assez infrarouge
elle va absorber l'énergie de ces
infrarouge lorsqu'elle les intercepts
même motif même punition l'atmosphère va
chercher elle aussi à se mettre à
l'équilibré énergétique et pour se
débarrasser de l'énergie qu'elle absorbe
quand elle est à l'équilibré énergétique
elle elle n'a qu'un seul moyen à sa
disposition elle peut pas évaporée de
l'ol va tout ce qu'elle peut faire c'est
re rayonner de la frange est donc ce qui
va se passer c'est que quand vous
intercepter les infrarouges émis dieu de
la surface vous les intercepter voulait
répéter mais vous allez en remettre dans
toutes les directions
donc une partie par vers l'espace il va
finir
à remettre la planète à l'équilibré
énergétique de l'espace mais une autre
partie retournerait hall et donc
contribuer à un deuxième chauffage du
sol
après le chauffage direct de du
rayonnement solaire alors en termes de
watts par mètre carré
le rayonnement infrarouge issus de
l'effet de serre est presque aussi
important que le rayonnement solaire
mais comme je ne sais plus qui a dit que
pays il ya le sigma t4 évidemment ça ne
double pas la température des équilibres
du sol mais ça augmente quand même de 30
degrés donc si l'effet de serre naturel
n'existait pas bonne nouvelle pour ou
secours n'aurait pas lieu
mauvaise nouvelle vous n'existe riez pas
parce que la terre serait trop court
trop loin du point triple de l'eau pour
que la vie ait pris place en tout cas
pas celle qu'on connaît donc l'effet de
serre naturel
c'est une très bonne chose il a permis
l'apparition de la vie et soit dit en
passant par une espèce de magie de l'
équilibre des processus
il a augmenté à mesure que pardon il a
baissé et l'effet de serre naturel à
mesure que la puissance solaire
augmentait parce que depuis que les
toiles du soleil ses formes et sa
puissance a augmenté et il ya eu une
espèce d'évolution quand ils hâtive à la
fois de l'effet de serre et de la
puissance solaire qui fait que la
température de la planète ne s'est
jamais beaucoup éloignés du point triple
de l'eau enfin en dessous elle est
jamais descendu sous point triple de
l'eau partout donc le voilà donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez d'assez
remarquable
on va dire ça marche
là dessus on arrive nous alors on arrive
nous et l'histoire que je vous ai
raconté au premier cours c'est-à-dire en
arrive nous avec nos machines nos vaches
et nos un puis deux puis trois puis cinq
puis 7 8 milliards de bipèdes alors ce
faisant nous allons mettre en route des
activités qui crée des émissions
additionnelles de gaz à effet de serre
en fait des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la planète en fait tout seul aussi
mais nous on en rajoute et comme c'est
ce gaz à effet de serre ont la sale
manie de ne pas vouloir s' évacuer
rapidement l'atmosphère une fois qu'on
les ya mis
j'y reviendrai et bien à ce moment nous
allons augmenter la concentration
atmosphérique en gaz à effet de serre
donc on va augmenter l'opacité de
l'atmosphère au rayonnement infrarouge
émis par la planète
si on augmente l'opacité de l'atmosphère
au rayonnement infrarouge émis par la
planète ça
dire qu'on va intercepter encore mieux
ce qui est émis par le sol et de ce fait
on va encore plus entre guillemets
réchauffer la basse atmosphère qui va
encore plus les maîtres dans tous les
sens dont vers le sol et donc on va
intensifier le chauffage du sol donc
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre
engendre une augmentation de la surface
planétaire alors comme on augmente le
chauffage du sol et bien le sol va faire
ce qu'il savait faire avec le
rayonnement solaire de départ c'est à
dire qu' il va augmenter tous les termes
il va augmenter tous les termes de
restitution d'énergie du sol vers
l'atmosphère
donc on va augmenter la chaleur de
contact on va augmenter l'évaporation
condensation et on va augmenter le
rayonnement infrarouge émis et on va
l'augmenter jusqu'à temps que ceux qui
arrivent à passer à travers l'atmosphère
ce qu'on appelle la fenêtre
atmosphérique soit redevenu identique à
ce qu'on avait avant d'augmenter les gaz
à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère dit
autrement on va revenir à l'équilibré
énergétique vue de l'espace
mais dans l'intervalle on apprend un
temps si fier les flux d'énergie entre
le sol et la basse atmosphère
alors quand vous voyez cette petite
animation oui
ils les retiennent pas il d absorber les
absorber une ére m c'est un phénomène
d'absorption réémission les infrarouges
qui viennent du soleil c'est infrarouge
de courte longueur d'onde c'est pas les
mêmes d'accord alors que c'est ce qu'on
appelle les infrarouges pour infrarouge
c'est tout ce qui va au delà du visible
donc c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
qui est extrêmement précis en ce qui
concerne les voilà donc on a tendance
enfin on a coutume pardon de les
classifier en infrarouge proche ce qui
est très proche du visible dans la même
gamme du même ordre de grandeur de
longueur d'onde et les infrarouges
lointains qui sont beaucoup plus loin ce
que vous comprenez tout de suite en
regardant cette animation c'est que les
mouvements convectifs ou plus exactement
les phénomènes extrêmes qui trouvent
leur origine dans des mouvements
convectifs vont faire quelque chose
entre guillemets les phénomènes extrêmes
qui trouvent leur origine dans les
mouvements convectifs vous avez les
ouragans
vous savez qu'un ouragan ça démarre par
quelques jours une convection importante
avec une température de surface de
l'océan qui doit être élevée pour
vouziers beaucoup d'évaporation
vous avez les orages vous avez les
tornades et tous ces phénomènes vous
comprenez que le moteur va augmenter
parce que la surface se réchauffe
l'évaporation augmente mais
corrélativement comme une part
croissante des infrarouges terrestre est
absorbé près de la surface il y en a
moins pour réchauffer la stratosphère
donc en fait on va voir ça dans vos
prochains cours là une des marques de
l'effet de serre c'est que la
température de surface augmente mais la
température de la stratosphère dix
minutes du coup vous allez augmenter
gradient de température dans la basse
couche de l'atmosphère ce qu'on appelle
la troposphère les premiers 10 km et si
vous augmentez le gradient de
température vous augmenter la puissance
convective donc vous allez
nécessairement à cause du processus même
qui est en cause changer la façon
changer la dynamique des phénomènes
extrêmes ou des phénomènes intense sur
le plan météorologique
alors je reviens une fois que je vous ai
expliqué ce qu'était l'effet de serre
pour comprendre la suite il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est
que comprendre l'évolution du climat ça
ne roule sous l'effet des activités
humaines ça ne relève pas d'une seule
discipline scientifique dans la presse
on voit souvent traîner le terme de
climatologues et alors quand on voit ça
on se dit bahain climatologues c'est un
spécialiste de l'évolution du climat
alors en fait spécialiste de l'évolution
du climat ça n'existe pas en tant que
tel à aucun moment il ya eu des
disciplines qui s'appelait spécialistes
de l'évolution du climat sous l'effet
des activités humaines ce qui s'est
passé sur les trente dernières années
c'est qu'il ya une instance de mise en
commun des compétences de tout un tas de
gens qui s'est créée sous l'égide des
nations unies qui s'appelle le giec ou
ipcc en anglais ce qui veut dire
internacional panel on climate change et
en français on traduit sa part groupe
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat qui consiste à demander à des
chercheurs de mettre bout à bout les
trouvailles de tout un tas de
disciplines scientifiques pour donner
une vision globale de ce problème qui
est l'évolution du climat soul est sous
l'effet des activités humaines mais ça
ne relève pas que d'une seule discipline
scientifique alors par exemple je vous
ai dit que le climat planétaire
changeait sous l'effet de l'attraction
des planètes
eh bien vous avez besoin
d'astrophysiciens pour comprendre la
mécanique céleste même sens aux planètes
du reste vous en avez besoin vous avez
besoin de dynamisme de la poster c'est
pas les mêmes vous avez besoin de
chimistes de l'atmosphère
c'est pas les mêmes vous avez besoin
d'océanographes s'est toujours pas les
mêmes etc dont vous avez besoin d'un
certain nombre de
pour ceux d'entre vous par exemple qui
ont entendu parler d'un homme s'appelle
jean jouzel jean jouzel il est à ranger
plutôt dans la catégorie des
glaciologues c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
sa thèse sur la teneur isotopique en
oxygène 18 si ma mémoire est bonne dans
les grêlons donc pas qu'il est parti
donc voilà donc vous avez besoin de tout
un tas de spécialité et il a fallu un
tour de force à la communauté
scientifique pour demander à tous ces
gens là de se parler pour donner d'une
seule voix avec un guichet unique
d'accès à l'information dont qui
s'appelle le giec une vision de ce qu
est l évolution du climat sous les
activités humaines
alors pourquoi est ce que je vous dis ça
parce que quand vous allez interviewer
un scientifique dans la presse aucun
d'entre eux n'a à cause de son travail
j'insiste à cause de son travail une vue
sur l'ensemble de ces disciplines
il peut en avoir une avec ses lectures
soit ça lui a évidemment pas interdits
comme à vous mais c'est pas son travail
qui va lui donner une expertise de même
niveau sur tout ce que vous avez
évoquées ici donc j'insiste là dessus
parce que c'est important de savoir que
vous n'avez pas encore une fois de
climatologues c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas alors des fois on donne
j'ai envie de dire le l'acception la
plus proche de climatologues qu'on
puisse trouver dans la communauté
scientifique c'est modélisateurs le
climatologue c'est celui qui fait le
modèle qui intègre les compétences de
tous ses collègues
bon à la limite ça voilà c'est là la
définition la moins mauvaise mais c'est
quand même quelque chose qu'il est
important de garder en tête alors je
disais que je me trompe toujours entre
1824 et 226 et ben voilà vous avez la
réponse est dans 1824 la bonne date et
donc 1826 les gaz de schiste à l'est des
états unis donc 1824 l'effet de serre
est identifié par joseph fourier vous
avez entendu parler de joseph fourier un
tout petit peu donc notre ami publie un
article dans lequel il dit il ya quelque
chose dans l'atmosphère qui fait que les
températures au sol sont plus élevés que
si ce quelque chose n'existait pas donc
il ya deux siècles quasi 1 à quelques
années près eh bien il ya un
scientifique français
cocorico qui comprend que les
températures au sol sont augmentés par
le rôle de l'atmosphère
vous avez quelques décennies plus tard à
nouveau un français puis un irlandais
qui identifie les deux principaux gaz à
effet de serre que nous avons dans
l'atmosphère qui sont le dioxyde de
carbone et la vapeur d'eau donc le fait
qu'il y ait un effet de serre et qu'ils
soient provoqués au premier ordre par la
vapeur d'eau et dioxyde de carbone ça
plus d'un siècle et demi en 1896
un suédois monsieur arrhenius qui se
trouve puisqu'elle est de votre
génération être un des ancêtres de greta
tout bergues
enfin pour la suède est un petit pays
après il faut peut-être tous français de
quelqu'un donc qui se trouvait donc un
de ses ancêtres à ses heures perdues
ce qui pouvait pas regarder la télé à
l'époque fait un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur sur ce qui se passe si on
double la quantité de gaz carbonique
dans l'air est alors monsieur arrhenius
dit deux ou trois choses qui sont
absolument fondamentales
il dit ainsi je double de la quantité de
co2 dans l'air la température planétaire
monte en moyenne de 4 degrés donc en
1896 il ya un premier calcul d'ordre de
grandeur qui tombe sur le bon résultat
paraît-il un peu par chance pas d'hier
mais l'autre mais quand même et par
ailleurs arrhenius comprend probablement
à cause du rayonnement du corps noir
soit dit en passant que si on a un
supplément d'effet de serre c'est à dire
un supplément d'interception des
infrarouges terrestre que vous avez
partout à la surface de la planète et
bien l'augmentation de température qui
en résultera toutes choses égales par
ailleurs sera d'autant plus marqué que
la température de départ et basse
car pour une même puissance rayonnée
vers le sol plus la température de
départ est basse et plus l'élévation de
température est importante à cause de
tes 4 et donc arrhenius dit à cette
époque là quelque chose qui est
parfaitement vrai et qui aujourd'hui
permet de dire que c'est bien l'effet de
serre qui est à l'oeuvre ça augmentera
plus vite au pôle que enfin si à plus
d'effet de serre la température
s'élèvera plus vite au pot luck aux
tropiques
or c'est très exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer
s'élèvera plus vite la nuit que le jour
et c'est également ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est lèvera plus vite
l'hiver que l'été et c'est également ce
qui est en train de se passer donc
arrhenius a compris c'est deux choses là
en 1896 à la fois que ça monte de 4
degrés et que la structure spatiale de
cette élévation de température porte une
signature particulière qui est bien
celle qu'on va retrouver aujourd'hui on
savait que les anglais sont un peu fous
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont créatifs
ils sont à la fois conservateur est fou
et donc il ya quasiment un siècle
il ya un anglais qui imaginent de faire
une simulation numérique mais à l'époque
n'ai pas d'ordinateur donc comme y'a pas
d'ordinateur il dit je prends des
physiciens donc tous les ingénieurs des
mines enfin bref ce qu'il dit je vais et
elle a un orchestre tous les dirigé à la
baguette pour leur faire faire la
résolution des équations une manière
éditeurs des intérieurs les autres alors
évidemment ça marche pas mais dès qu est
le premier ordinateur et mis au point et
vous verrez quelques unes de ses
caractéristiques dans un des prochains
cours eh bien il ya des physiciens qui
se jettent dessus pour faire le premier
modèle de simulation du comportement de
l'atmosphère
donc l'idée que l'on puisse utiliser les
outils numériques
c'est à dire des modèles pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui va se passer plus tard
c'est pas apparue avec la dernière
version de jeux vidéo c'est quelque
chose qui est très très anciens au
regard de la de la science climatique
aussi il ya un truc que je vous ai pas
mis dans cette chronologie que j'aurais
dû vous m
j'y reviendrai après c'est le moment où
on commence à on a découvert les
spectromètres de masse qui permettent de
faire des analyses isotopiques parce que
ces analyses isotopiques sont absolument
crucial pour reconstituer les
températures du passé donc il ya une
autre date extrêmement importante c'est
les années 70 c'est à ce moment là que
on est capable d'analyser des sédiments
ou d'une manière générale des
échantillonnages prélever ici et là sur
la croûte terrestre dont des fameuses
glaces polaires et avec des analyses
isotopiques de reconstituer des
marqueurs du climat passé les chasser
les années 70
alors je voulais dit un gaz à effet de
serre à une définition extrêmement
simple c'est un gaz qui possèdent des
red absorption dans l'infrarouge
terrisse d'accord sur la définition à
gaz à effet de serre il se trouve que
cette propriété physique n'est
accessible qu'au gaz qui sont triés
atomique ou plus donc un gaz dit
atomique monoatomique a fortiori un gaz
rare ne peut pas avoir deux raids
absorption dans l'infrarouge terrestre
donc l'oxygène et transparent à
l'infrarouge terrestre l'azoté
transparent à l'infrarouge perez et
larron aussi par contre vous avez la
vapeur d'eau tri atomique qui possèdent
des raies d'absorption
vous avez le dioxyde de carbone c'est à
tomic qui possèdent des raies
d'absorption vous avez le méthane qui a
cinq atom qui possèdent des raies
d'absorption le protoxyde d azote qui
possède également des raids absorption
et on va revenir à tous et voilà et des
gaz qui sont las du pur légaux inventés
par les hommes qu'on appelle des
halocarbures c'est des hydrocarbures
dans lesquels on a substitué tout ou
partie de l'hydrogène par une molécule
d'allogènes donc du chlore du fluor rom
etc
on verra pourquoi on fait ça qui sont
également des gaz à effet de serre
extrêmement puissant et enfin il ya un
dernier gaz qui est à gaz à effet de
serre qui est l'ozone donc l'ozone
c'est le couteau suisse de l'absorption
il fait tout ce qu'il absorbe les
infrarouges terrestre lycée absorber les
infrarouges thérèse plus exactement il
sait aussi absorber les ultraviolets du
soleil
alors oui je voulais dit l'effet de
serre est quelque chose de naturel sur
terre puisque comme vous avez de gaz
présents dans l'atmosphère naturellement
qu'ils sont des gaz à effet de serre la
vapeur d'eau et le co2 vous avez une
méthane pardon vous avez de l'effet de
serre sur terre depuis que vous avez
dans l'atmosphère du co2 du méthane et
de leur apport d'eau c'est à dire depuis
quatre milliards et demi d'années
l'atmosphère primitive de la terre a
notamment été formés par le volcanisme
qui a conduit à des gros dégazage de co2
donc dans l'atmosphère primitive de la
terre vous avez déjà du co2 donc l'effet
de serre
c'est une histoire vieille de quatre
milliards et demi d'années sur terre
soit dit en passant
cet effet de serre comme il est
au volcanisme primitif on a une planète
qui s'est également formé une atmosphère
dans laquelle il y en avait beaucoup
c'est une planète tellurique elle a une
densité de matière qui est proche de la
nôtre qui est venus venus a
vraisemblablement eu une atmosphère
primitif qui s'est formé comme la nôtre
sauf que comme vénus n'a pas porté la
vie venus n'a jamais eu les changements
atmosphériques que nous avons connues
sur terre avec d'abord l'apparition de
méthane à cause des bactéries primitives
qu'on appelle les arcs et puis
l'apparition d'oxygène avec les plantes
primitives puis plus développés qui ont
mangé le co2 et qui ont créé de
l'oxygène donc l'atmosphère de vénus
elle a toujours 90 95 % de co2 et à la
surface de vénus avec 90 ou 95 % de co2
vous avez un effet de serre assez coquet
puisque la température de surface
dépasse les 400 degrés la différence
entre vénus et la terre
c'est aussi que l'angle d'un perception
de vénus est plus important puisque
venus est plus près du soleil
mais si vous regardez quel est l'impact
de cet angle d'interception plus
important vous fait que vénus soit plus
près du soleil sur la température d'
équilibre vous allez trouver quelques
dizaines de degrés seulement on peut
nouvelle pour rousset pas l'exercice que
je vous donnerai à la fin de secours
donc ça n'explique pas pourquoi vous
avez 400 degrés de plus par rapport à la
température planétaire ce qui explique
ses 400 degrés de plus pour l'essentiel
c'est l'effet de serre de vénus
extrêmement puissant puisque vous avez
encore une fois plus de 90 % de co2 dans
l'atmosphère alors je ne pense pas que
votre vivant vous verrez ça moi non plus
du reste
cela étant c'est juste là pour montrer
que l'intensification de l'effet de
serre peut très très fortement changé le
climat d' équilibre une planète
ça peut très fortement le changer
l'homme a donc une action aujourd'hui
sur la composition atmosphérique et la
manière dont il a cette action c'est au
travers de ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre
le premier gaz à effet de serre que nous
émettons en importance mais après je
vous dirai comment calcule d'importance
c'est le gaz carbonique ou dioxyde de
carbone le dioxyde de carbone vous avez
ici c'est 5 cause planétaire qui sont
d'origine humaine
la première c'est la déforestation alors
puisque la déforestation émet du co2
c'est quoi en pratique la déforestation
oui
alors on quand on déforeste ça veut dire
qu'on supprime la forêt donc il y avait
des arbres
donc on les a coupés qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait essentiellement on les brûle
l'essentiel de la déforestation c'est du
défrichage
c'est à dire que on coupe la forêt pour
installer des surfaces à vocation
agricole
mais même quand le bois coupé est
exploité en fait vous avez une petite
partie seulement du bois qui va vivre
longtemps dans une forêt française
vous avez 7 7% seulement d'un arbre qui
est coupé qui est du bois d'oeuvre à
longue durée 10 tout le reste ça va
rentrer dans des produits qui vont être
soit très courte durée de vie
typiquement du papier les emballages etc
soit à durée de vie raisonnablement
courte
typiquement le meuble ikea qui ne va pas
survivre il va pas vous survivre le
magic a donc voilà donc ça rentre dans
des produits qui sont à durée de vie
relativement courte et donc une fois que
le produit a fini sa vie est bien le
carbone surtout dans l'atmosphère parce
qu'en général c'est brûler oui
oui c'est totalement négligeable donc là
ce que vous allez retrouver ces deux
choses c'est à la fois le carbone qui
était contenu dans l'arbre qui va passer
dans l'atmosphère parce que encore une
fois on a essentiellement brûlé c'est
que juste je réponds à la question
et la deuxième chose que vous allez
trouver c'est que quand vous transformer
un stock de forêt en sols agricoles
vous allez labouré en labourant vous
exposer le bus à l'oxygène de l'air et
donc vous allez aussi des stocker du
carbone par oxydation de façon accélérée
vous diminuez le contenu en carbone du
sol et c'est ces deux processus a ajouté
l'un à l'autre qui font les émissions de
co2 provenant de la déforestation
oui alors donné c'est des millions de
tonnes
donc ça c'est des milliards de tonnes
enfin vous enlevez les 3 0 vous avez des
milliards de tonnes
mais pardon j'aurais dû préciser donc
vous avez ici la déforestation
alors ce que vous constatez c'est que la
déforestation est passé par une forme de
maximum il ya quelques décennies alors
elle continue elle est importante
la raison pour laquelle vous avez des
fluctuations importantes ici là vous les
aviez pas avant c'est tout simplement
que maintenant on a des statistiques sur
des durées et c'est un bien dépistage
c'est qu'on a des statistiques sur des
pas de temps plus court que celle qu'on
avait avant vos qu'avance lycées par
ailleurs apprécié la déforestation de
manière statistique est un problème
beaucoup plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît
pas ce que ça se fait essentiellement
avec des observations satellitaires
mais si vous défend restait sur une
parcelle qui est sous la résolution sous
le pixel de l'image vous voyez pas si
vous enlevez un arbre sur deux et que
les houppiers des arbres restent à peu
près comme il était avant vous voyez pas
cirfa bongo qui a plein de trucs que
vous pouvez ne pas voir avec l'imagerie
satellite donc savoir exactement combien
d'arbres on a coupé c'est plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît après vous avez ici un
deuxième terme qui est le dioxyde de
carbone qui vient de l'utilisation du
charbon alors utiliser du charbon comme
du pétrole comme du gaz confère ce que
je vous avais dit la dernière fois c'est
une réaction exothermique provoqué par
de l'oxydation encore vous prenez un
composé de carbone et d'hydrogène
s'appelle un divan carbure dans des
proportions variables beaucoup de
carbone solide moyen de carbone liquide
peu de carbone gazeux et vous
si des et ça vous donne une réaction
exothermique qui va vous permettre
d'alimenter des machines donc ça c'est
dioxyde de carbone qui vient du charbon
du pétrole et du gaz et alors là vous
avez un truc qui en anglais s'appelle la
calcination et en français s'appelle
calcination du calcaire dans lequel six
nations du calcaire à ce que c'est
pourquoi on fait un truc pareil sinon
absolument le calcaire c'est quoi la
formule du calcaire caco3 le ciment
c'est essentiellement de la chaux vive
seao avec tout un tas de poudre de
perlimpinpin que vous rajoutez dedans un
peu d'argile un peu de marne un peu de
machins et bien c'est pour ça soit dit
en passant qui a déjà fait de la
maçonnerie ici bon vous avez remarqué
que si vous mettez pas de gants à la fin
de la journée vous avez la peau des
doigts complètement bouffé donc parce
que le ciment comme c'est de la chaux
vive plus des poudres de perlimpinpin ça
vous agresse c'est un occident c'est
d'accord ça vous agresse la peau donc
les liant hydraulique d'une manière
générale sont son vous agresser pour
faire c'est à eau à partir de caco3
c'est très simple vous prenez une grande
paire de ciseaux et vous couper en deux
d'accord dont vous prenez caco3 vous
mettez ca ou d'un côté et co2 de l'autre
alors c'est quoi la grande paire de
ciseaux qui vous permettent de casser la
molécule en deux ça s'appelle un four
dans lequel vous portez votre calcaire à
un peu plus de 1000 degrés comme dans
les indestructibles la ville de rennes
et vous récupérez donc d'un côté c'est à
eau et de l'autre côté co2 évidemment
co2 vous en faites rien donc il part
dans l'atmosphère est bien ce que vous
avez ici en line calcination c'est le
co2 issu des fours à ciment qui provient
de cette structure de la molécule de
carbonate de calcium en deux ça n'inclut
pas le co2 provenant de l'énergie qui
vous a été nécessaire pour chauffer le
four ça c'est pas dedans c'est en plus
là c'est juste la quête citation du
calcaire alors ici je vous donne une
vision par source
maintenant je vais vous donner une
vision par zone
c'est un peu plus long comme échelle de
temps puisque nous partons de 1750 vous
n'étiez pas né
moi non plus vous voyez qu à cette
époque des émissions il n'a pas beaucoup
irakien quelques-unes d'akon
quelques-unes et on va regarder comment
évolue
les émissions au fil du temps alors ce
que vous voyez c'est que vous avez des
émissions des pays anciennement
industrialisés
là où ici dit qu on trees qui augmente
qui augmente qui augmentent et qui aux
tendances depuis le pic énergétique dont
j'ai parlé l'avant dernière fois à se
stabiliser
non là vous avez l'ancien bloc
communiste c'est ça qu'on appelle les
économies en transition
ici vous avez l'asie et notamment la
chine et vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui elle
a dépassé la zone ocde mais que c'était
extrêmement rapidement et enfin là vous
avez d'autres d'autres pays envoyer
quelques petites quelques petites
évolutions il ya quelques petites
informations sur cette courbe alors vous
pouvez faire le la récession de 1929
vous voyez ce que ça vous donne en
évolution annuelle sert vous avez un
coup vers le bas et en tendance pas
grand chose retenez quand même que à la
fois la crise de 29 son paroxysme plus
exactement c'est à dire l'année 1932 et
le paroxysme de la guerre de 39-45
c'est-à-dire l'éradication industrielle
de l'allemagne et du japon en 1945 c'est
les deux sols épisode au cours du 20e
siècle où les émissions annuelles ont
baissé de 4 % ou plus il ya eu deux
années en cours du 20e siècle où les
émissions annuelles ont baissé de 4%
c'est 1932 et 1945 alors retenez bien
parce que si on est sérieux sur l'accord
de paris il faudrait faire ça tous les
ans à partir de maintenant en démarrant
la semaine prochaine jusqu'à ce que vous
ayez mon âge tous les ans il faut faire
tous les ans dans le monde
un effort qui est du même ordre de
grandeur que ce qu'on a obtenu dansé
pendant ces deux années là rigolez pas
ça va être à vous de le faire ici vous
avez un choc pétrolier
bon vous voyez je vous récite place
qualifiera qu mais j'y pense très fort
là vous avez une petite récession
bon ça dure pas très longtemps là vous
avez une très forte croissance qui a été
le décollage industriel de la chine
et là par contre vous avez quelque chose
qui a été très efficace
faire baisser les émissions c'est
l'effondrement économique des pays
communiste après la chute du mur marche
pas très bien vous verrez la prochaine
fois que malheureusement ça marche très
très bien c'est bien ça qui pourrait
marcher in fine et pour respecter le
fait que le monde est finie parce que
pour le moment on a un drame dans cette
histoire que voici vous ai montré au
cours du premier cours que plus de pib
en fait ça voulait dire plus de flux
productif que le flux était par
définition mesurée par l'énergie donc
que ça voulait dire plus d'énergie et
que comme l'énergie est essentiellement
fossiles ça veut aussi dire plus de co2
donc ce que vous voyez sur sept ce
graphique c'est le drame des
négociations climat c'est le drame
comme disait l'autre parce que faire
moins d'émissions de co2 de manière
massive
aujourd'hui personne ne sait pas même
moi concevoir ça sans faire une baisse
significative du pib
personne ne sait faire ça aujourd'hui
on y reviendra mais en gros personne de
ces faits ressent donc le drame des
négociations climat il a et je ne sais
pas qui dans la salle connaît brice
lalonde dans les deux vieux du fonds
alors brice lalonde a été candidat
écologiste dont il a fait ces quelques
pour cent des voix en france à une
époque où non seulement vous n'étiez pas
d'aimer moi j'étais pas vieux il a été
ambassadeur climat de la france et il
était notamment à copenhague
on était ensemble à copenhague en 2009
et il a fait tout les coptes donc c'est
très simple depuis elle adore du récit
les élèves qui organise des conférences
ici veulent inviter un jour à faire une
conférence et un très bon orateur il a
une façon très imagée est très parlant
de raconter un milliard d'anecdotes et
donc brice a dit un jour qu'il a fait
tout les copains depuis le début et il a
dit le problème des négociations climat
c'est que depuis l'origine les pays
occidentaux viennent en pensant qu'on va
parler climat les pays en développement
viennent en pensant qu'on va parler
développement et ses développements qui
gagne parce que comme je vous le
rappelle la plus exactement sur une
démonstration c'est un rappel
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire plus de
pib sans utiliser plus de machine est
donc plus d'énergie on verra dans les
jours qui viennent si on peut utiliser
que de l'énergie décarbonée est vrai que
c'est pas si simple
ici vous avez la trajectoire des
émissions de co2 de la france
alors vous voyez qu'en séries longues et
bien on est à peu près comme les autres
c'était tout petit ça augmente et il ya
des accidents etc
aucun des accidents n'empêche vraiment
la hausse tant que la production
économique croit il ya un truc quand
même qui a bien calmer le jeu c'est le
programme nucléaire français que vous
voyez ici
cela étant maintenant les émissions dès
qu'on a la possibilité de faire croître
le pib ce que on aimerait bien faire
quand on est au gouvernement en ce
moment en irak pas trop mais c'est pas
parce qu'on n'est pas parce qu'on le
souhaite eh bien les émissions ont
tendance à repartir à la hausse
aussi ce graphique vient du dernier
rapport du giec et il donne la
contrepartie j'ai envie de dire de la
variation des émissions sur les quatre
dernières décennies
en fonction de ces de l'équation de
kayar à qui connaît déjà ici les
pressions caillan versements suivants
vous ennuierez pas trop la prochaine
fois alors les messieurs l'équation de
caillasser une équation qui décomposent
les émissions de co2 en cas de termes
qui sont respectivement la population le
pib par personne
l'intensité énergétique du pib et
l'efficacité co2 de l'énergie et ce que
disent ces quatre bars là c'est que vous
avez eu un rythme de variation des
émissions toujours positif qu'une
croissance des émissions sur les quatre
dernières décennies qui est le triangle
que vous avez là mais ça se décompose en
une amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie qui est la
barre jaune une amélioration de
l'efficacité carbone de l'économie sur
les trois premières décennies de ce
graphique mais pas la dernière décennie
que vous voyez ici ça se dégrade
en fait c'est l'essor industriel de la
chine et l'explosion du charbon et vous
avez également deux autres termes qui
sont la population et la production par
personne dit autrement
en plus nous sommes nombreux plus toutes
choses égales par ailleurs nous émettons
malheureusement arithmétique est par
ailleurs plus nous créons de flux
physiques à base de machines par
personne c'est à dire plus nous créons
de pib par personne plus nous avons une
grande quantité d'énergie utilisée
et comme cette énergie et fossiles plus
nous émettons donc dit autrement
depuis les quatre décennies qui viennent
de s'écouler
l'augmentation démographique et
l'augmentation de la transformation de
l'environnement par personne c'est ça le
pib par personne sont allés plus vite
que les gains que vos prédécesseurs
sortie de cette même école ont pu faire
dans les machines que nous utilisons
pour vivre c'est-à-dire la quantité de
co2 qu'on met dans l'air quand on
utilise un kilowattheure est la quantité
de machines ou la quantité kilowattheure
qu'il faut utiliser pour faire un dollar
de valeur ajoutée d'accord ces deux
paramètres techniques ont constamment
évolué moins vite dans le bon sens que
les deux paramètres qui pousse les
émissions à la hausse non évoluer dans
l'autre sens petit zoom sur la
déforestation
vous voyez que les zones qui ont
déforester ne sont pas les mêmes en
fonction des époques
vous voyez en particulier qu'il ya un
siècle et demi le champion du monde de
la déforestation et l amérique du nord
aujourd'hui le champion du monde de la
déforestation
c'est plutôt l'asie du sud-est après que
ça a été longtemps l'amérique latine
alors cela étant ça défaut reste encore
dans plein de pays dans le monde
la déforestation à deux déterminants
très simple le premier comme on
déforeste pour augmenter les surfaces
cultivables
le premier des feux le premier
déterminant c'est la taille de la
population donc plus la population croît
plus on déforeste très simple et le
deuxième déterminant c'est plus un
régime et carnets plus vous allez avoir
besoin de surfaces agricoles importantes
pour nourrir les bêtes ce que vous allez
manger au lieu de manger directement les
végétaux qui pousse et donc plus vous
avez une surface par personne importante
enfin plus vous avez besoin
surface par personne importante qui est
évidemment prise là on peut la prendre
c'est à dire sur la forêt donc je vais
te dire de manière beaucoup plus résumé
est beaucoup plus cash
il ya deux drivers deux déterminants
essentiels à la déforestation c'est
l'augmentation de la population et
l'augmentation de la part carnet dans
l'alimentation
c'est ça les deux déterminants
essentiels de la déforestation
je vous ai montre oui que ya moins d'eau
qu'un couple et en europe
le minimum forestier je voulais 10 au
cours du premier cours c'était 15 % de
couverture de la surface européenne en
1850 et donc on s'est arrêté déforester
parce qu'essentiellement il y avait plus
rien à couper parce que 15 % c'est aussi
à peu de choses près les forêts qui
couvrent les montagnes des très hautes
latitudes voilà là où en gros vous avez
pas envie d'aller mettre des trucs à
cultiver quoi mais toute la beauce a été
déforester toute la plaine aquitaine a
été déforester et c'est à la forêt
landaise a été replanté par derrière
donc vous avez essentiellement quand
vous avez toutes les plaines qui sont
occupées ou zara clic à quelques
exceptions près en raw cp ce1 il y avait
nos questions d'accord dit autrement
quand vous trouver un équilibre entre la
population et les surfaces cultivables
vous arrêtez de déforester donc ou bien
à cet équilibre il est trouvé par la
limitation j'ai envie de dire par la
famine donc à un moment les surfaces
cultivables et les rendements faut que
vous pouvez pas augmenter la taille de
la population
donc vous avez déforester tout ce qui
pouvait être déforester sauf les
mentalités machin comme ça je suis même
ça vous pouvez un peu d'efforts restent
maîtres des cultures en terrasse comme
henri saivet
ou bien le point d'équilibré se trouve
avant est alors en particulier aux
etats-unis un des trucs qui a aussi
entre guillemets sauver les forêts c'est
les tracteurs et les engrais parce que
quand vous augmenter les rendements à
l'hectare des cultures vous n'avez pas
besoin d'aller chercher des surfaces
ailleurs il soit dit en passant quand on
dit qu'il faut faire de l'agriculture
extensive
ça se met à reposer le problème de la
déforestation puisque si vous avez le
même régime alimentaire en provenance
d'une surface moins productives vous
avez besoin de plus de surface donc là
vous avez un conflit d'usagé vide enfin
conflit d'objectif plus exactement
évident entre trois trucs qui sont la
viande les phytosanitaires les engrais
et la déforestation est très compliqué
vous avez ici maintenant une autre
manière de voir les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui ne sont pas les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
de la population dans son ensemble mais
qui sont les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par personne alors par personne
vous allez me dire c'est évident c'était
extrêmement faible au début de l'ère
industrielle et puis ça a explosé après
si vous regardez le co2 qui provient à
des combustibles fossiles
oui puisque le marqueur de l'ère
industrielle c'est d'avoir justement
utiliser des machines qui mangent des
combustibles fossiles
si vous rajoutez le co2 issues de la
déforestation
alors vous voyez que le tableau n'est
pas du tout le même en un siècle et demi
les émissions de co2 par personne n'ont
été multipliés entre guillemets que par
deux et demi que par deux et demi alors
que sur la même période la population
humaine
ll a été multiplié par 6 5 ou 6 donc
voyez que les émissions de co2 par
personne ont n'ont pas n'ont pas
augmenté mais les émissions liées à la
déforestation fortement baissé et
évidemment les autres ont compensé
petit zoom sur la france ici vous avez
les émissions de co2 tricolore il est
vraiment trois couleurs sur ce graphique
vous constatez que aujourd'hui elles
sont inférieures à ce qu'elles étaient
au moment du premier choc pétrolier on a
moins d'émissions de co2 et vous voyez
en particulier que celle du pétrole et
du charbon ont fortement baissé alors le
pétrole a été chassée des usages
industriels et d'une partie du chauffage
par le gaz et l'électricité le charbon a
été chassée des usages industriels pour
deux raisons la première c'est que une
fois que la france a fini de construire
ces infrastructures
on a besoin de moins produire d'acier or
un des gros consommateurs de charbon
c'est la chirurgie on a fait moins
d'électricité au charbon ainsi une
deuxième raison et on en a utilisé moins
dans l'industrie
par contre vous voyez que le gaz avait
tendance à augmenter ses émissions de
co2 en fait ça c'est s'il est vrai
depuis le milieu des années 2000 lorsque
vous voyez c'est qu'on a quand même une
tendance lourde
sur ce graphique alors quand vous la
hausse oui ça c'est des émissions brutes
y'a pas l'absorption des forêts là
dedans c'est vraiment les émissions
brutes la comptabilisation des pluies
est un truc indémodable j j'en parlerai
rapidement mais c'est un truc très
compliqué donc les émissions brutes de
co2 ce que je voulais juste vous montrer
c'est que en france elles ont plutôt
tendance à baisser depuis le choc
pétrolier 6 soit dit en passant est
envoyé dans le journal as
les émissions ont augmenté par rapport à
l'année dernière on regarde la série
longue que je vous montre là qu'est ce
que vous pouvez en déduire
n'en déduisez rien quand vous êtes en
train de regarder une évolution sur
série longue
vous voyez qu'il ya des petits machins
qui monte qui descend qui monte qui
descendent et c'est quand vous avez ce
genre de truc la seule conclusion vous
pouvez en tirer syrien voilà ça
n'empêche pas les gens qui ont besoin
d'actualité de vous dira c'est parce que
ceux ci c'est parce que cela c'est parce
que machin etc
en fait sur une année vous en tirez
essentiellement la conclusion que
attendons de voir
alors c'est évidemment ennuyeuse que je
suis en train de vous dire parce que
dans un monde qui est régie par la
réaction de court terme de ne pas être
capable de faire une attribution des
causes précises sur ce qu'on est en
train d'observer c'est ennuyeux ici vous
avez la même chose discriminés par
secteurs d'utilisation
alors il ya quelques éléments qui sont
assez frappant sur 7 sur ce graphique
d'abord ce que vous voyez c'est que
l'ordre dans lequel les émissions arrive
aujourd'hui n'est absolument pas l'ordre
dans lequel ça arrivait au moment du
maximum au premier choc pétrolier à ce
moment là l'essentiel de l'utilisation
en fin d émission de co2 étaient le fait
de l'industrie et pas du tout des
transports comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
ce que vous voyez c'est que les
émissions de co2 de l'industrie à partir
des chocs pétroliers ont très fortement
baissé ce qui est une autre manière de
dire que l'industrie et le secteur dans
lequel la consommation est la plus
sensible au prix est ce que vous savez
pourquoi
parce que tout brillant ingénieur des
mines que vous êtes dans votre vie
personnelle vous compterez beaucoup
moins attentivement ce que vous faites
que dans votre vie professionnelle
donc dans la vie professionnelle les
gens sont beaucoup moins sensibles
malgré ce qu'on vous apprend en économie
nous ne sommes pas que des êtres
rationnels et donc vous est beaucoup
moins sensible aux variations de prix
que l'on peut l'être dans les
entreprises ont fait des tas de calcul
extrêmement savant pour savoir si on
peut pas gagner 3 centimes ici plutôt
qu'en perdre deux là et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle le secteur
industriel est beaucoup plus sensible à
des variations prix que le secteur des
particuliers ça réagit plus vite et du
reste vous voyez que la même variation
des cours du pétrole
appliquée à l'industrie ici sache ça
change fortement la donne alors que là
ça ne change à peu près rien la
consommation de pétrole dans les
transports a évolué avant après à peu
près de la même manière après vous avez
un deuxième endroit où ça se met à
bouger significativement c'est les
industries de l'énergie c'est à dire les
centrales électriques et les raffineries
et ça c'est essentiellement le fait des
centrales électriques
on avait de plus en plus de charbon de
pétrole et de gaz dans les centrales
électriques on en a de moins en moins
notamment du pétrole
et on se met à tous remplacés par du
nucléaire vous voyez les faits ici vous
voyez également dans les bâtiments donc
résidentiels résidences et le tertiaire
enfin choisir des bâtiments plus
exactement que ça se met également
abaissé est le seul secteur dans lequel
sarah continuer d'augmenter ses les
transports cela étant vous voyez que
dans les transports ça a tendance à
baisser depuis le milieu des années 2000
et c'est pas un effet de la conscience
climatique parce que c'est en effet que
vous constatez dans tous les autres pays
européens
au même moment c'est un effet du stress
régionale d'approvisionnement en
hydrocarbures liquides dont je vous ai
parlé au cours précédent
c'est un effet de ça si on prend tous
les gaz à effet de serre confondues
voilà comment ça se décompose vous avez
toujours les transports qui arrive en
fait mais par contre vous voyez alors
bon il faut bien regarder ici voyais
l'agriculture qui est tout en bas et
vous voyez l'agriculture qui remonte
beaucoup plus haut
je ne vais pas détailler pour le moment
parce que je vais revenir après c'est
lié au fait que ça et mais d'autres gaz
que simplement le c'est quoi ces clubs
théâtre qui à côté où bon leur demandait
de faire un tout petit peu moins de
bruit ou fermer la porte non je pense
que ça va régler le problème
ce qu'on revient donc à nos moutons
la quantité de co2 dans l'air augmente
je voulais montrer tout à l'heure j'y
reviendrai après en nous expliquant
comment est ce qu'on mesure ça sur
longue période
cette quantité de co2 qui augmente on a
une cause naturelle qui pourrait la
conduire à augmenter
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure qui est
c'est la cause qui à faire paraître le
co2 dans l'atmosphère primitive de la
terre à volcanisme
si le co2 apparaît dans l'air par le
volcanisme au moment où j'ai une
augmentation de la quantité de co2 dans
l'air
est-ce que j'ai une raison particulière
de constater une diminution corrélative
de la teneur en oxygène
oui ou non non
ce que vous voyez ici c'est la variation
de la quantité de co2 dans l'air avec en
fait la variation saisonnière est ici
vous avez la variation de la quantité
d'oxygène dans l'air c'est évidemment
sur une échelle extrêmement dilatés et
vous voyez qu'il ya également une
variation saisonnières alors est ce que
vous savez à quoi correspond cette
variation saisonnière non il avait
encore droit aux coups de fils et un ami
et aux 55 ans oui non ces saisonniers
dont la nuit c'est oui exactement
vous savez que la terre possède deux
hémisphères qui sont très dissymétrique
en ce qui concerne les surfaces émergées
vous avez beaucoup plus de surface
émergée dans l'hémisphère nord que vous
n'en avez dans l'hémisphère sud
ce qui veut dire que au moment où c'est
le printemps dans l'hémisphère nord est
où les plantes sont en croissance
la végétation en croissance va pomper du
co2 en provenance de l'atmosphère alors
que de l'autre côté dans l'hémisphère
sud
vous avez beaucoup moins de plantes qui
vont ceux qui vont enfin de plantes à
feuillage caduc qui vont avoir des
feuilles qui vont pourrir ce qui conduit
le co2 à retourner dans l'atmosphère
parce qu'en fait une fois une feuille
qui pourrit c'est une feuille qui se
décompose sous l'action microbienne et
les microbes respire comme vous et donc
la respiration microbienne remet de
l'oxygène enfin remettre du co2 pardon
dans le dans l'atmosphère comme vous les
microbes l'absence de l'oxygène et
rejette du co2 donc quand c'est le
printemps et l'été dans l'hémisphère
nord
la teneur en co2 de l'atmosphère
planétaire a tendance à légèrement
baisser
par contre quand c'est l'hiver l'automne
et l'hiver dans l'hémisphère nord
la teneur en co2 de l'atmosphère a
tendance à légèrement ré augmenter et
donc autour d'une tendance lourde qui
est piloté par nos émissions de co2 vous
avez une oscillation saisonnière que
vous voulez très très bien dans les
relevés sur la teneur en co2 si cette
oscillation saisonnière va
corrélativement avec une oscillation
saisonnières de l'oxygène ça veut dire
que
et que par ailleurs la tendance lourde à
l'oxygène c'est une légère baisse de sa
concentration
ça veut dire que toute molécule de co2
qui apparaît dans l'air a pris une
molécule d'oxygène dans l'air on est
d'accord et donc ça veut dire que ça n'a
pu apparaître ce co2 que par oxydation
d'un carbone qui était disponible pour
être oxydé or vous avez deux endroits où
le carbone est disponible pour être
oxydé
vous avez la végétation la décomposition
des feuilles mortes
mais vous avez aussi et c'est ça la
tendance la combustion des combustibles
fossiles et c'est normal que la
combustion des combustibles fossiles
retire un peu vous allez dès stocker du
carbone de soupe sol et corrélativement
vous allez déstocker un peu d'oxygène de
l'atmosphère vous l'assemblée les deux
ça vous fait plus de co2 donc ce que
vous dit cette courbe sur l'oxygène
c'est que c'est bien un processus de
combustion ou d'oxydation du carbone
plus exactement qui est à l'origine de
l'apparition du surplus de co2 dans
l'air
c'est une des manières qu'ont à de
montrer que le carbone qui le surplus de
co2 qui apparaît dans l'atmosphère vient
bien vient bien de quelque chose qui se
passe à la surface de la planète et pas
par exemple du volcanisme
il ya une deuxième analyse qu'on est
capable de faire sur ce co2 qui montre
que ça vient bien de chez nous c'est
vous avez entendu parler du carbone 14
alors le carbone 14 est ce que vous
savez comment il se forme il se forme
par transmutation de la zone dans la
haute atmosphère sous l'effet des rayons
du rayonnement cosmique donc sous
l'effet du rayonnement cosmique
vous avez de la zot dans la haute
atmosphère qui absorbe c'est plus un
autre ou un proto enfin bon bref qu'il
ya une indigestion et qui se transforme
en carbone 14 ce carbone 14 après
rentrer dans le cycle du carbone il va
donc être ingérés par des êtres vivants
quand vous avez des combustibles
fossiles qui sont d'anciens êtres
vivants ça fait des dizaines de millions
d'années qui sont sous terre ils ont
totalement perdu leur carbone 14
donc les émissions de co2 qui viennent
des combustibles fossiles doivent
appauvrir l'atmosphère en carbone 14
alors ce qui vient de la vie c'est un
cycle du carbone 14 a durée de vie
courte
la repousse sa dure quelques dizaines
d'années
une quelques siècles ibr crac ça repart
dans l'atmosphère c'est une durée trop
courte pour que ça change
fondamentalement la teneur de
l'atmosphère en carbone 14 par contre
quand vous déstocker des combustibles
fossiles et vous rajoutez du co2 qui lui
est totalement dépourvu de carbone 14
ça vous change la teneur isotopique de
l'atmosphère en carbone 14 et c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'on constate
actuellement c'est aussi quelque chose
qui permet de dire l'augmentation du co2
dans l'atmosphère ça vient bien de chez
nous bon ça je vais passer parce que
j'ai pas le temps et puis c'est pas le
plus important
le co2 oui
non c'est beaucoup trop plein
perceptible j'ai dit à l'heure s'est
dilaté
on parle de parties par million donc on
parle là pour le co2 on parle de faire
passer la teneur en co2 de 0,03 pour
cent à 0,04 % ou 0 05 % de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
si vous enlevez 0 0 1% ou 0 02 %
d'oxygène de l'atmosphère
ça fait une différence de pression
partielle sur l'oxygène qui est beaucoup
plus faible que quand vous allez au ski
et vous avez constaté que vous revenez
vivante du ski
enfin jusqu'à maintenant donc là il
rigolait pas un chômeur il n'a pas eu
autant de chance mais bon donc ce que
donc cette cette diminution de la teneur
en oxygène n'est pas suffisante pour que
ça soit un problème par contre
l'augmentation de la teneur en co2 de
l'atmosphère à des niveaux plus élevés
que ceux dont on parle aujourd'hui mais
pas considérablement plus élevé ça peut
devenir un vrai problème
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui sont en
train de regarder si à 1000 ppm de co2
dans l'atmosphère on commence pas à
avoir des problèmes sanitaires
récurrents pour absolument tout le monde
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle l'inca 400
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à 10% de co2
dans l'atmosphère mouret toxicité aiguë
du co2 et c'est pas juste parce que vous
étouffe et je peux vous mettre 20 %
d'oxygène au même moment c'est le top
six sites et donc le co2 dans
l'atmosphère il vaut mieux pas qu'il en
ait trop vous avez du reste constaté que
quand vous êtes dans une atmosphère
qu'on appelle vicié dans une pièce qui a
pas été aéré vous pouvez avoir un peu
mal à la tête
ça c'est un des effets possibles du co2
alors j'y reviens le co2 est un oxyde
dioxyde de carbone vous savez vous parce
que vous l'avez appris en chimie que les
oxydes sont des molécules qui sont
extrêmement stable c'est très stable un
oxyde le faire quand on trouve
aujourd'hui sous forme de dioxyde a pas
de pardon de effet deux ou trois pas du
dioxyde de fer dans les gisements de
minerai de fer ça fait des milliards
d'années enfin depuis que les continents
sont ap
rue et que le faire cet oxyde et ça fait
des milliards d'années que c'est sous
forme d'oxydé de fer puis c'est resté
comme ça je veux dire c'est extrêmement
sale alors cette stabilité du co2 cette
stabilité chimique s'applique aussi au
co2 que nous avons mis dans l'atmosphère
une fois que le co2 émis dans
l'atmosphère
vous n'avez pas de processus chimiques
d'épuration de ce gaz il n'y a pas de
processus chimiques d'épuration du co2
de l'atmosphère
vous n'avez que deux processus
d'épuration j'y reviendrai plus tard
qu'ils sont un processus physiques le
co2 peut se dissoudre dans l'eau
océanique
en fait c'est un équilibrage de pression
partielle entre l'atmosphère et l'océan
et le co2 peut être photo synthétiser
c'est à dire qu' il peut être absorbé
enfin plus exactement métabolisé par une
plante mais c'est une réaction
endothermique il vous faut un photon
dont spontanément vous n'avez pas de
réactions chimiques du co2 avec
n'importe quoi dans l'atmosphère le
corollaire de cette affaire c'est qu'une
fois que le co2 se retrouvent dans
l'atmosphère
il va donc enfin que le surplus de co2
est créé dans l'atmosphère plus
exactement son temps d'amortissement le
temps qu'il faut attendre pour que le
surplus de co2 s'évacue après arrêt des
émissions est extrêmement élevé donc ce
que vous voyez ici c'est que une fois
que le que vous arrêtez les émissions
vous attendez plus d'émissions et bien
ce que vous dit ce graphique c'est que à
siècle après vous avez 40 à 50% du
surplus qui sera toujours au dessus de
nos têtes
donc un siècle après c'est même pas au
dessus des vôtres vous serez déjà mort
milan après vous aurez toujours de
l'ordre de 20% du surplus qui sera au
dessus de nos têtes et dix mille ans
après vous aurez toujours de l'ordre de
10% du surplus qui sera toujours au
dessus de nos têtes
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que le processus du
changement climatique n'a aucune
réversibilité aucune
alors il n'y a pas un bouton reset sur
lequel on peut appuyer un jour en disant
merde comme disait petit gibus ça si
j'avais su j'aurais pas venu
et qui permettrait de recommencer
l'expérience à 0 on peut pas recommencer
l'expérience à 0 c'est une expérience
qui sera faite une fois et une seule et
à cause de cette inertie absolument
considérable du co2 dans l'atmosphère
une autre chose que vous pouvez déjà
gardé en tête dès à présent c'est que
les conséquences du changement
climatique sur lesquels je détaillerai
un certain nombre de choses la prochaine
fois la seule garantie que vous avez
c'est qu'au moment où vous commencez à
considérer enfin vous nous l'humanité au
moment où on considérera qu'elles seront
intolérable la seule garantie qu'on aura
à ce moment là c'est que ça sera pire
derrière à cause de cette stabilité du
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
d'accord oui
on met du co2 parce qu'on oxydes des
combustibles fossiles et bien les arbres
ne mangent pas suffisamment vite parce
qu'ils sont limités par la photosynthèse
oui partiel non et après dans les
conséquences dont je vous parlerai une
des conséquences est que vous allez
affaiblir les écosystèmes terrestres
donc en plus ils vont avoir moins envie
de manger de co2 qu'avant vous avez un
certain nombre de processus de
rétroaction dans cette affaire dont je
parlerai la prochaine fois qu'ils sont
des processus qu'on appelle positif
c'est-à-dire d'amplification
c'est à dire que les premières
conséquences du processus amplifie
processus et vous en avez un certain
nombre que je détaillerai la prochaine
fois donc là vous avez évidemment la
résultante de tous les effets ces
émissions compte tenu du fait qu'il ya
des absorptions et vous voulez donc je
le redis des absorptions vous n'avez que
deux équilibrage de pression partielle
entre la poster et l'océan
c'est physique réaction endothermique
photosynthèse vous avez besoin d'un
photon besoin d'énergie cette affaire-là
va donc se s'appliquer à des échelles de
temps qui dépassent l'entendement et
surtout qui dépasse le temps
caractéristiques d'un mandat électoral
dans les démocraties et qui soit dit en
passant dépasse également très largement
la stratégie de long terme de votre
employeur futur s'il est cotée en bourse
il reste même s'il n'est pas coté en
bourse donc les les horizons de temps
qui sont en cause dans ce processus dont
je rappelle ce que j'ai dit au début
c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas accessible
à vos sens
le rappel ça quand même et bien pas
céder moyenne tout ça est bien le temps
caractéristiques de ce processus va très
très au delà du temps caractéristiques
des modes de gestion que nous avons on
va dire démocratisé par bon du mauvais
jeu de mots à la surface de la planète
c'est à dire ce que nous avons rendu
courant alors maintenant il n'ya pas que
le co2 dans la vie il ya d'autres
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
vais y venir
mais le co2 en fait quand je vous dis il
y en a une partie du surplus qui s'en va
en fait il reste pendant un certain
temps et après sa concentration diminue
de plus en plus fortement
vous avez d'autres gaz pour lesquels les
faits radiatif instantanée beaucoup plus
fort par contre ils peuvent
éventuellement rester beaucoup plus
longtemps et vous en avez un
dans cette affaire qui est un gaz qui
est important aussi dans les discussions
que le méthane le méthane un forçage
radiatif instantanée qui est beaucoup
plus important c'est que quand vous
mettez un kg de méthane dans
l'atmosphère
ça vous intercepte beaucoup plus
efficacement les infrarouges t rès que
quand vous mettez un kilo de co2 par
contre le méthane lui il a un processus
chimique d'épuration de l'atmosphère il
se fait manger par les radicaux
hydroxyles et donc il va y rester moins
longtemps
c'est le seul gaz qui est un processus
chimique d'épuration de l'atmosphère pas
à ce stade ce qu'on sait pas ce que je
vous ai montré la cour tout à l'heure
c'est que la quantité de co2 depuis
qu'on a des mesures instrumental
c'est-à-dire 1958 augmente rapidement
dans l'atmosphère mais on n'est pas
encore capable de comparer ça avec ce
qui se passait à des périodes plus
anciennes
alors pour comparer ça avec des périodes
plus anciennes
on va avoir besoin d'aller faire un
petit tour aux pôles alors pourquoi est
ce qu'on va faire un petit tour au pôle
parce que au pôle est un truc qui nous
intéresse beaucoup
en tant qu'art chiffres climatique c'est
les calottes la prochaine
le processus de formation d'une calotte
c'est quoi on va prendre l'antarctique
parce que maintenant 90 c est vrai ce
que je vous raconte sur l'essentiel de
la surface de l'antarctique
vous avez des températures qui sont
négatives toute l'année ce qui veut dire
que quand il ya des précipitations
c'est nécessairement sous forme de neige
par ailleurs des précipitations vous en
avez très peu
l'antarctique est un endroit très froid
c'est un endroit extrêmement sec
donc vous avez peu de précipitation
chaque chaque année quand la neige
dont année après année vous avez des
précipitations neigeuses et ces
précipitations neigeuses comme elle ne
fondent pas comme un domaine ne font pas
donné pas de fonte ce qui va leur
arriver c'est que elles vont se tasser à
cause du poids des chutes de neige
successives et ce processus de tassement
au bout de quelques siècles fini par
transformer la neige glace quand vous
avez un processus de transformation de
neige en glace simplement parler de
pression au moment où cette neige se
transforme en glace
elle va emprisonné sous forme de petites
bulles l'air qui circule entre les
flocons
alors vous alliez de l'air qui circulait
entre les flocons et dans le processus
de tassement cette terre est emprisonné
sous forme de petites bulles et donc
vous allez retrouver dans la glace
prisonnière sous forme de petites bulles
l'atmosphère qui fossiles qui date de
l'époque de formation de la glace après
cette glace elle reste pas au même
endroit
il se trouve que elle va en règle
générale flux et vers l'océan
d'accord c'est un processus
d'accumulation est pareil fait graviter
pas sous le poids de sa propre glace
c'est un peu fluide la glace ça flux et
s'affilie quelques temps après aux
milliers d'années dizaines de milliers
d'années centaines de milliers d'années
millions d'années par donner des
icebergs
quand vous allez bien choisir l'endroit
où se trouve le carottage parce que
c'est ça dont on va parler bientôt et
bien il se trouve que vous avez une
petite portion de la glace qui dans ce
processus dans cette dynamique elle elle
fut essentiellement verticalement
d'accord donc elle s'enfonce sans aller
se balader vers les côtes
ce qui veut dire que si vous allez faire
le trou pile au bon endroit et bien dans
un carottage verticale vous allez au fur
et à mesure de la profondeur pardon de
la profondeur de la carotte récupérer de
la glace de plus en plus ancienne avec
une atmosphère fossiles de plus en plus
ancienne et toutes les espèces chimiques
contenus dans cette atmosphère qui sont
stables une fois que la bulle s'est
formé
ce qui est le cas du co2 ce qui est
aussi soit dit en passant le cas du
méthane parce qu'une fois que le méthane
vous l'avait retiré du contact avec les
radicaux hydroxyles de l'atmosphère
ils cessent de disparaître d'accord donc
le méthane que vous retrouvez dans les
bulles d'air
formé dans la glace lui il représente la
concentration en méthane que vous aviez
au moment où la bulle ses formes et
enfin en moyenne sur quelques siècles
alors la manière dont on prélève une
carotte c'est très simple ici vous avez
un carrossier le quartier voilà donc
vous le mettez à la surface de la
carotte vous faites un grand forage donc
un antre où vous avez compris au moment
du pétrole que le trou on était les rois
du trou savez très bien faire ça ils ont
vous récupérez voilà une carotte de
glace
alors voilà à quoi ressemble une carotte
de glace qui est beaucoup plus précieuse
évidemment que celle qui finira dans
votre whisky
là on est en train de la deûle à sortir
du tube on l'a coupé en petits morceaux
on étiquette soigneusement les morceaux
pour dire à quelle profondeur ça a été
prélevé et on en voit ça au laboratoire
j'ai plus comment il s'appelle
maintenant qui est à grenoble et qui
étudie ce qui a dans les 40 dans les
carottes on va trouver de trucs on va
trouver à la fois à la glace elle même
et en analysant la composition
isotopique de l'eau c'est-à-dire la
fraction d'oxygène 18 ou la fraction de
deutérium dans l'hydrogène de l'eau on
est capable de reconstituer la
température planétaire de l'époque parce
que au moment où l'eau s'évapore
vous avez ce qu'on appelle un
fractionnement isotopique c'est à dire
que plus la température au lieu
d'évaporation et chaudes et plus la
vapeur d'eau emporte en proportion plus
d'oxygène 18 et +22 terium qui
évidemment ensuite vont précipiter
partout dans le monde y compris en
antarctique pour former la neige de la
calotte
donc quand la teneur isotopique en
oxygène 18 et en deutérium dans la glace
de la calotte c'est un marqueur de la
température planétaire et vous allez
trouver l'air buzy l'air dans les
petites bulles et l'air dans les petites
bulles lui il va vous marquez la teneur
en co2 en méthane protoxyde d'azoté ça
marche aussi que vous avez dans
l'atmosphère des temps anciens oui
alors comme en antarctique vous allez
trouver de l'eau qui précipite après
avoir été évaporé sur toute la surface
de l'océan
globalement c'est un marqueur de la
température planétaire
alors pour le co2 c'est également un
marqueur du co2 planétaire parce que
comme la durée de vie du co2 dans
l'atmosphère ce conte ancien cmo
millénaire pas du surplus de co2 alors
que le temps de brassage intérêts
hémisphérique de l'atmosphère c'est de
l'ordre de l'année en gros vous émettez
du co2 absolument n'importe où mais
c'est juste un jeu c'était à plus tard
mais peu importe vous émettez du co2
n'en avais vous évitez du co2 absolument
n'importe où les concentrations vont
sauver j'ai des idées très vite et donc
comme en plus à cette époque là vous
avez peu de source concentrée de co2
susceptible de perturber localement j'ai
envie de dire la mesure parce que si
vous aviez un volcan juste à côté de la
carotte c'est un peu emmerdant mais là
en l'occurrence et paca eh bien vous
avez un marqueur de la concentration en
co2 de la delà de l'atmosphère dans son
ensemble alors quand vous analysez ces
concentrations en gaz à effet de serre
dans les cales dans les glaces décale
alors pardon vous pouvez faire ça en
antarctique
on pouvait faire ça au groenland pour
les temps anciens vous ne pouvez plus
faire ça au groenland des temps modernes
parce qu'il ya plein d'endroits au
groenland où maintenant la neige fond
surface de la calotte et donc à ce
moment évidemment vous avez plus ce
phénomène d'accumulation année après
année qui vous donnent des strates qui
sont bien daté dans le temps une partie
de ce qu'ils t'ont bruxelles fiche le
camp ailleurs et c'est probable donc
c'est plus du tout exploitables donc ce
que vous avez ici c'est donc la
concentration en co2 en méthane et en
protoxyde d'azoté pas aux mêmes échelles
mais peu importe
alors vous voyez que jusqu'au début de
l'ère préindustrielle tout ça est stable
et arrive l'ère industrielle
et vous voyez la concentration qui se
met à évoluer de façon extrêmement
rapide à la hausse
on sait aujourd'hui remonter avec la
carotte la plus ancienne qu'on et
préserve la plus profonde plus
exactement qu'on ai prélevées en
antarctique à environ 800 mille ans et
donc sur huit cent mille ans on est
capable de reconstituer la concentration
en co2 que vous avez et en méthane que
vous avez dans et je vous ai mis à
l'échelle
ici les surplus de concentration que
nous avons déjà créé en l'espace d'un
siècle et demi ou deux siècles
ce que vous voyez c'est que à l'échelle
des temps géologiques où les variations
climatiques ont engendré ou sont allés
de pair avec des variations de gaz à
effet de serre là en l'occurrence c'est
plutôt les forçages astronomique change
la température sur terre et ça ça change
la concentration d'équilibré gaz à effet
de serre ges au prochain coup est bien
là vous voyez donc ça va rien peu mais
vous voyez qu'on est déjà totalement
sorti de la variation naturelle avec ce
qu'on a rajouté les périodes grise est
ici c'est les périodes interglaciaires
chaudes telles que celle qu'on avait
commencé à vivre depuis des bilans et
vous voyez que ça correspond à des
concentrations plus élevées de gaz à
effet de serre alors en ce qui concerne
le co2 c'est le processus de déstockage
du co2 de l'océan qui est à l'oeuvre le
l'eau chaude 10 ou moins bien le co2
clos froide donc quand vous avez un
forçage astronomique qui vous réchauffe
la température de la planète
ça vous réchauffe les océans à ce moment
les océans des gaz un peu de co2 et soit
dit en passant ça vous réchauffe en plus
la planète
à un moment le phénomène philippaerts
s'amortir et s'équilibrer mais vous avez
un phénomène d'amplification
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
sorties de glaciation vont beaucoup plus
vite que les entrées en glaciation parce
que vous avez ce phénomène
d'amplification de rétroaction positive
en ce qui concerne le métal c'est plus
chaud et plus humide voulait dit tout à
l'heure puisque c'est un cycle de l'eau
qui s'intensifie un donc plus de zones
humides donc plus d'émissions de méthane
puisque le métal naturel est
essentiellement émis par les zones
humides
c'est un marqueur des zones humides
puisque pour faire du méthane de manière
naturelle faut vous dire un endroit où
la végétation pour ico en eau à l'abri
de l'oxygène de l'air
alors oui le chef typiquement les
marécages et c'est donc plus vous
augmentez les zones humides
plus vous augmentez les émissions de
méthane et la question évidemment est où
est-ce qu'on est parti dans tout ça
à l'avenir alors ce que vous voyez c'est
que avant même de parler d'avenir
la discontinuité que nous avons
introduites dans l'atmosphère est
extrêmement brutal au regard de ce qui
se passe sur les temps géologiques et à
cause de la durée de vie du co2 dans
l'air en forme d'un surplus de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
même avec des émissions qui demain matin
baissent très fortement nous sommes
encore très loin d'avoir vu la totalité
des conséquences de ce que nous avons
déjà fait on a pas on n'est pas dans un
système instantanée dans lequel les
conséquences sont immédiatement après
les émissions on a on verra ça la
prochaine fois ça va s'étaler sur des
milliers d'années après les émissions
voilà donc la question c'est est ce que
on contacte c'est pas aujourd'hui est
loin s'en faut
la concentration en co2 la plus élevée
que nous ayons eue dans l'atmosphère
planétaire
on a eu des époques géologiques ancien
où la concentration en co2 était
beaucoup plus élevé qu'aujourd'hui alors
ici vous avez un marqueur de la quantité
de co2 que vous avez dans l'atmosphère
depuis le début de l'ère primaire et
s'est exprimé aux multiples de la
concentration actuelle envoyée il ya des
moments où il ya eu trente fois enfin
fois pardon plus de co2 peut-être même
il ya longtemps mais c'est époque-là on
aussi correspondu à des époques où la
puissance solaire était plus faible est
par ailleurs à cette époque là il y
avait probablement très peu de vie sur
les terres émergées les terres émergées
est encore essentiellement les déserts
et la ville était essentiellement dans
l'océan dans le changement climatique
dont on parle aujourd'hui le sat
ma vie c'est que la probabilité que le
changement climatique et je fis pour
l'été que le changement climatique et
cause l'éradication de toute vie sur
terre vous paraît assez faible ce qui va
être en jeu évidemment c'est où se
déplace le curseur sur les endroits où
ça se passe bien et les endroits où ça
se passe moins bien c'est ça la c'est ça
la question
mais ça va évidemment pas supprimé la
totalité de la vie sur terre
oui alors la quantité de co2 je viens de
l'expliquer depuis qu'on a des océans la
quantité de co2 est un peu piloté par le
rayonnement solaire puisque quand le
rayonnement solaire conservé par la
planète avec la variations de ses
paramètres astronomiques est plus
importante
les océans se réchauffent et ça dégage
un peu de co2 donc là vous avez un
processus de de pilotage quand vous avez
la végétation qui se porte bien ce qui
s'est passé après l'apparition de la
végétation au cambrien est bien là vous
avez corrélativement le co2 qui baisse
voilà donc vous avez des processus
évidemment d'asservissement entre le
rayonnement solaire
la quantité de végétation et le co2 dans
l'air mais ce qui est important dans ce
que je suis en train de vous raconter
c'est la vitesse à laquelle le processus
évolue c'est une affaire de vitesse
cette histoire pour reprendre quelque
chose que vendent en parlerons des
conséquences si vous rentrez dans un mur
à trois kilomètres heure vous avez une
bosse si vous y rentrer à 100 km/heure
est mort donc là on parle exactement de
la même chose il ya des déplacements du
système qui sont pas gênant parce qu'ils
sont faits sur des durées lente et donc
il ya des adaptations possibles et il ya
des déplacements du système qui sont
plus enquiquinant parce qu'ils sont sur
des durées qui sont trop courtes pour
que le système puisse s'adapter dans de
bonnes conditions
alors malheureusement on est parti sur
la 2e option c'est ça qui est ennuyeux
pour ça qu'il faut il passer cinq heures
nous n'avons pas que le co2 dans les gaz
à effet de serre je voulais dit tout à
l'heure alors j'y reviens une fois qu'on
sait qu'on n'a pas que les gaz à effet
de serre dans la sphère pour ceux
d'entre vous c'est à dire normalement
tout le monde si la collectivité fait
bien son travail qui vont un peu
s'intéresser à la question du changement
climatique dans leur métier futur
comme c'est un truc
il faut que tout le monde s'y intéresse
un peu vous allez avoir besoin d'une
métriques qu il n'y a pas qu'un seul gaz
à effet de serre si avec un seul gaz à
effet de serre ça serait simple la
métrique c'est le poids de co2 et puis
on a que du co2 on mesure emploi de co2
c'est plus grave des maîtres trois kilos
que d'émettre 1 kg mais comme on a
plusieurs gaz à effet de serre du
méthane le protoxyde d azote là est-ce
que c'est plus grave d'émettre 1 kg de
méthane ou est-ce que c'est plus grave
des maîtres kg de co2 si mon patron me
dit t'as 1000 euros pour réduire quelque
chose et que j'ai la possibilité de
réduire le méthane de 3% ou le co2 de
10% qu'est ce que je choisis
eh bien vous ne savez pas répondre à
cette question tant que vous n'avez pas
une unité de comparaison une monnaie
c'est à dire quelque chose qui vous
permet de dire ça c'est x fois plus
graves où il soit moins grave que le co2
alors cette monnaie elle s'appelle le
prg le prg ça veut dire le pouvoir de
réchauffement global
c'est là le forçage radiatif cumulé que
va vous amener une unité de gaz à effet
de serre supplémentaires dans
l'atmosphère est plutôt que de regarder
en absolu on a choisi de que cette unité
soit une unité relative donc en fait
c'est le rapport entre le forçage
radiatif cumulés d'une unité de gaz à
effet de serre sur une durée donnée sur
le forçage radiatif sur la même durée de
du même poids de co2 ce qui veut dire
que par convention le prg du co2 vaut 1
quel que soit l'horizon de temps
concernées d'accord
cette unité dépend de l'horizon de temps
et elle dépend du forçage radiatif alors
je vais revenir à la cour que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure celle là vous
voyez que si je prends par exemple ce
gaz là qui est un halocarbures et que je
bornes mon horizon de temps à une année
eh bien je vais avoir un rapport comme
on est logarithmique 10/100/1000 dix
mille fois ça se paie rejette ce truc
travail de dix mille fois supérieur au
prg du co2 mais si je bornes
mon horizon de temps à milan et bien ce
truc là ce sera épuré beaucoup plus vite
que le co2 et donc en fait mon rapport
d'intégrale parce que c'est ça c'est mon
rapport d'intégrale sur un horizon de
temps donné il va avoir une valeur
extrêmement différentes
d'aucun débat alors qu'il peut vous
paraître un débat un peu technique
soporifique tatillon qui est c'est quoi
la bonne échelle de temps alors c'est
pas du tout un débat tatillon parce que
selon les chaînes de temps que vous
prenez en particulier pour le méthane le
méthane
il est à un siècle 20 fois en 25 fois
plus nocif que le co2 mais à 20 ans il
est cent fois tout 80 plus nocif que le
co2 alors je prends 20 où je prends un
siècle
et bien si je prends 20 ans la nouvelle
zélande qui aimait plan de méthane parce
qu'elle a plein de moutons et vaches se
met à hurler
pareil pour les pays qui cultive du riz
alors que si je prends un siècle c'est
les pays qui ont plus de co2 dans leurs
inventaires d'émissions qui se met à
hurler en dix jours non ça ne
désavantagent cette carte donc vous
voyez que ce sujet là qui peut paraître
comme un peu technique est anecdotique
en fait il pilote la façon dont on va
répartir la charge de l'effort en
fonction des sources d'émission oui
parce que la culture du riz émettent du
méthane que j'y reviendrai un peu plus
tard
une rizière c'est un marécage artificiel
dont vous avez des débris organiques qui
se décompose à l'abri de l'oxygène de
l'air quand vous avez une décomposition
anaérobie donc ça vous aimez du méthane
toutes les décompositions anaérobie
émettent du méthane
c'est le même principe soit dit en
passant aujourd'hui dans les
méthaniseurs dont il était entendu
parler on fait exactement la même chose
on met de la matière végétale à l'abri
de l'oxygène de l'air con fait manger à
des bactéries primitives qui s'appelle
des arcs et qui vous émettent du méthane
alors une fois que j'ai de métal
justement j'aurais pu vous dire cela tu
as donc on va pouvoir comparer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
voilà par exemple les émissions de
méthane
pour le moment je les compte en tonnes
de méthane ou plus exactement en
millions de tonnes de méthane
alors d'où ça sort mon méthane et bien
vous l'avez ici vous l'avez d'abord donc
rice pas 10 et les rizières ici dans
attendez je suis pas sûr que dans coal
mining
donc ça c'est la distribution de gaz
si les fuites dans les réseaux de gaz ce
que le gaz naturel c'est du méthane ça
c'est les mines de charbon
donc on faire ce que je vous ai dit la
dernière fois quand on forme une veine
de charbon il ya du méthane qui est
absorbé sur le charbon le rappeler et
donc quand on mean le charbon eh bien on
aimait du méthane dans l'atmosphère
passe confronted levin pour éviter que
les mineurs facebook ensuite au dessus
vous avez la combustion de la biomasse
alors qu est ce que la combustion de la
biomasse aimé du méthane parce que le
méthane c'est un élément volatil qui se
forme quand le bois prend feu et une
partie de ce méthane n'est pas brûlé au
moment où la combustion a lieu et donc
ils fichent le camp dans l'atmosphère au
dessus vous avez alors livestock c'est
le cheptel bovin
fabrice et les ruminants d'accord et là
dedans vous avez essentiellement des
vaches vous avez un milliard et demi à
deux milliards de vaches sur terre les
vaches représente la première biomasse
animal la première biomasse par dans les
mammifères homme animal c'est la
première biomasse de mammifères sur
terre devant les
hommes et les vaches roth du méthane
le pet très peu passive pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle rock du méthane parce que les
vaches sont supérieurs à vous et à moi
ils ont quatre estomacs au lieu d'en
avoir un et danser estomac vous avez un
processus complexe de fermentation
anaérobie donc à l'absence de l'oxygène
de l'air et dans ce processus de
fermentation anaérobie vous avez du
métal qui se forment et le dépeindre
ressort par les voix supérieur et ça
contribue aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre donc ici vous avez
effectivement les rizières
rayspan is donc c'est le processus que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est la
décomposition à l'abri de l'oxygène de
l'air est ici vous avez lands il ce qui
en français veut dire les charges
absolument pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
des émissions de méthane des décharges
même motif même punition parce que dans
les décharges vous avez notamment des
déchets organiques vous épluchures de
patates
enfin pour ceux d'entre vous qui épluche
des patates donc quand ça arrive dans
une décharge et bien vous avez les
déchets qui s'empilent les uns sur les
autres et une partie de ces déchets vont
donc faire monter à l'abri de l'oxygène
de l'air et donc les maîtres du métal
alors maintenant dans l'essentiel des
décharges des pays occidentaux se met à
les capter mais c'est pas par tous car
dans le dos un autre gaz à effet de
serre dont je vous ai parlé c'est le
protoxyde d'azoté
alors le protoxyde d'azoté même si ce
camembert est un peu anciens il est
toujours valable dans le dans dans ses
causes et dans ces ordres de grandeur
vous avez ici du protoxyde d azote qui
est issu des processus de combustion
vous savez que la combustion c'est un
processus dans lequel vous oxydé quelque
chose avec le l'oxygène de l'air mais en
général cet oxygène de l'air vous ne
l'aviez pas pur là où ça brûle vous
l'amener avec la zone de l'air et donc
le processus de combustion va vous
réarrangé la zot et l'oxygène sous forme
d'oxydé d'azoté donc les oxydes d azote
de la pollution automobile la dent vous
entendez peut-être parler et bien c'est
tout simplement la zot qui est rentré
dans le moteur qui s'est retrouvé dans
la chambre de combustion du moteur qui
sert combinée à de l'oxygène et qui
ressort sous forme d'oxydé d'azoté une
partie de ces oxydes d azote c'est du
propre
petite partie c'est la même chose dans
l'industrie et c'est la même chose d'en
transposer la même chose dans les
chaudières de partants dans les
chaudières de bâtiments vous avez une
cause essentielle qui est l'agriculture
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez des
émissions de protoxyde d azote en
agriculture
parce que l'agriculture utilise des
engrais que les engrais contiennent des
molécules adopté c'est ça un des apports
des engrais et des molécules azotés et
que ces molécules azotés quand vous les
épandez sur le sol et ça marche avec les
engrais de synthèse ça marche aussi avec
le lisier des cochons ou avec le purin
des vaches
eh bien ça il ya une petite partie des
docks de des molécules qui vont former
du protoxyde d'azoté sous l'effet de
l'action microbienne des sols donc ça
c'est des émissions des sols liés à
l'épandage des engrais azotés
après vous avez des molécules dites bâle
au carbure donc comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est des molécules qu'on
a fait en remplaçant dans les
hydrocarbures de l'hydrogène par des
allogènes alors presque on s'est amusé à
faire des trucs comme ça
tout simplement parce que la liaison ces
allogènes est une liaison qui est
extrêmement stable ce qui veut dire que
quand vous faites ce genre de composer
en particulier quand ils sont saturés
vous faites des molécules qui sont quasi
indestructible et donc qui ne sont pas
toxiques
c'est des molécules qui ont remplacé
d'autres usages
à cause de leurs propriétés physiques
intéressantes ou avant on utilisait des
gaz qui eux étaient potentiellement
toxiques ou agressif alors dans les
chaînes du froid ça a remplacé le co2
qu'on utilisait à un moment qui était un
peu moins bon sur le plan
thermodynamique et puis surtout
l'ammoniac
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
sont déjà amusé à respirer une grande
bouffée d'ammoniac non c'est pas
terrible donc on a préféré mettre dans
les circuits frigorigènes des molécules
de gaz halogénés parce que si vous en
respirer un grand coup il vous arrive
essentiellement rien j'ai totalement
inerte pareil pour les gaz propulseur
des bombes aérosols
on a utilisé ses gaz à la place des
hydrocarbures qu'on utilisait avant et
où les gamins quand j'avais l'âge d'être
un gamin faisait à wright ici en
enflammant le la flamme du machin vous
un chalumeau comme ça et puis comme il
ya quelques gamins qui sont fait péter
la figure avec ça on a remplacé sa part
un truc qui brûlait pas ça a également
servi de gaz ex penseurs de mousse donc
si vous avez un vieux frigo des années
50 qui traînent dans votre cave la
mousse isolante du frigo a été fait avec
un gars comme ça qui a servi de gaz ex
penseurs donc votre mousse
elle est truffée dalo carbure donc si
vous exposez vous détruisez la boue
c'est que vous exposez ça a l'air d'un
parent dans l'atmosphère mais ça
augmente effet de serre et enfin ça sert
également de solvants dans l'industrie
des semi conducteurs
le de plus dangereux pour la couche
d'ozone de ces halocarbures qui
s'appelait le cfc a depuis été éradiquée
alors le cfc et est une molécule très
stable comme tous les autres
chlorofluorocarbures que du chlore et du
fluor et du carbone mais comme c'était
très stable ça avait le temps de monter
dans la haute atmosphère sans être
agressé par quoi que ce soit sur le plan
chimique dans la haute atmosphère s'est
dissocié par les ultraviolets dur et à
ce moment le chlore libéré par cette
réaction agressent l'ozone
stratosphérique et donc on a supprimé la
production on n'a pas su priver les
émissions parce que vous avez des cfc
qui ont été utilisés précisément comme
gaz ex penseurs de mousse et donc ils
sont encore dans des vieux frigos qui
continuent d'être d'être démantelée
aujourd'hui on n'a pas complètement
supprimé puis à dr certain nombre de
pays qui en ont fait un peu en douce
on a remplacé sa part de gaz qui ont à
peu près les mêmes propriétés
thermodynamique dans les chaînes du
froid mais par contre qu'ils sont pas
agresseurs de la couche d'ozone par
contre c'est des gaz à effet de serre
extrêmement puissant voilà donc vous
avez toujours des gaz de cette nature
mais les émissions aujourd'hui ils sont
quand même beaucoup plus faible que ce
qu'elle était dans les années 50 après
vous avez un autre gaz à effet de serre
dont j'ai parlé qui n'a pas d'émissions
directes qui est l'ozone alors l'ozone
je leur dis vous avez deux endroits où
vous en avez vous en avez dans la haute
atmosphère celui-là nous intéresse
énormément
il nous intéresse à double titre il
intercepte les ultraviolets dur du
soleil donc ça c'est un premier truc qui
nous intéresse parce que sinon c'est
ultra violet dur
gênerait l'a dit telle qu'on la connaît
sur terre et il a un deuxième effet qui
est beaucoup plus méconnus qui est que
comme il absorbe de l'énergie dans la
haute atmosphère
il réchauffe donc la haute atmosphère et
il crée ce qu'on appelle une inversion
de température c'est à dire que la
température qui par effet
thermodynamique de base diminue quand la
pression diminue quand on monte jusqu'à
la tropopause c'est à dire jusqu'à la
limite de la stratosphère se met à se
réchauffer quand on rentre dans la
stratosphère et alors cette inversion de
température à quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental c'est qu'elles limitent la
convection de la vapeur d'eau à la
limite à la tropopause si la version de
température n'avait pas lieu
la vapeur d'eau ne s'arrêterait pas à 15
km du sol continuerait à monter plus
haut donc ça serait un peu gênant pour
les précipitations est par ailleurs la
vapeur d'eau sera exposée elle aussi aux
ultraviolets dur du soleil qui aurait
depuis longtemps dissocier l'eau en
oxygène qui serait resté sur terre et
hydrogène quand il foutu le camp parce
que la molécule est trop volatile
donc l'eau qui est arrivé sur terre
si la couche d'ozone n'avait pas créé
cette inversion de température
elle aura disparu et alors ça c'est
également quelque chose qui est
absolument crucial pour le maintien de
la vie sur terre
alors cet ozone stratosphérique il est
formé par interaction de l'oxygène
atmosphérique avec les ultraviolets il a
son propre cycle et il ne bouge pas de
la stratosphère et encore une fois on
aime beaucoup à cause des deux effets
que je viens d'évoquer plus près du sol
vous avez de l'ozone troposphérique de
l'ozone qui apparaît près du sol
alors celui là il nous intéresse
beaucoup moins il n'apparaît pas du tout
pour les mêmes raisons celui là il
apparaît avec parce qu'on joue au petit
chimiste en gros on met dans
l'atmosphère tout un cocktail c'est top
chef de la pollution c'est à dire que
l'on met dans l'atmosphère des oxydes
d'azoté des composés organiques volatils
on touille tout ça avec un peu de
rayonnement solaire ils sont peu de
rayonnement solaire et craque je vous
avais de l'ozone qui apparaît alors
celui là on n'aime pas du tout parce que
il rentre dans nos poumons et il
participe à l'effet de serre comme celui
ci on pouvait ne pas le voir
on préférerait ici vous avez des cartes
qui vous montrent que la concentration
d'à peu près n'importe quoi sur les
halocarbures a fortement augmenté au
cours des dernières décennies est ici
vous avez des cartes qui vous compare la
concentration de fond en ozone et vous
voyez que elle a extrêmement fortement
augmenté c'est à dire que bien que
l'ozone soit un occident très agressif
c'est que sa durée de vie dans
l'atmosphère soit courte parce que dès
qu'il est fort mais il trouve un truc à
bouffer et il jette dessus comme on
continue à en produire en permanence
vous avez une concentration de fond en
ozone qui est en permanence au dessus de
nos têtes
plus ou moins élevé mais en permanence
l'ozone retenait aussi ça a est un
inhibiteur de la croissance pour les
plantes
donc là où vous avez des concentrations
en ozone qui sont un peu élevées
et comme il faut le temps pour que
l'ozone se forme en région parisienne
par exemple c'est pas là où vous avez la
circulation routière que vous avez le
maximum de la concentration en ozone
en général il faut le temps de se former
donc le maximum de la concentration en
ozone en fonction du vent c'est toujours
un peu sous le vent de l'agglomération à
10 20 30 km sait jamais pile dans paris
c'est un inhibiteur donc de la
croissance des plantes alors une fois
que on a le comparatif des gaz les uns
avec les autres
on peut représenter oui
parce que c'est un inhibiteur de la
croissance des plantes puisque c'est un
effet constaté c'est pourquoi c'est
toujours un comment qui se ramènent au
pourquoi de la fois d'avant donc en fait
ça inhibe je ne sais pas trop quelle
réaction dans la photosynthèse
voilà c'est un inhibiteur de la
croissance une fois donc on a les
éléments de comparaison sur les gaz
entre eux on va pouvoir commencer à
représenter les gaz à effet de serre
sous forme les émissions exactement sous
forme de camemberts alors les camemberts
il y en a plein vous pouvez représenté
par gaz
vous pouvez représenté par source vous
pouvez représenté par pays tougas
confondues etc
je vais vous proposer un certain nombre
de camembert et je vais commencer
paradoxalement pas par le camembert dans
lequel il ya les gaz les uns par rapport
aux autres ou
après mais je vais commencer par un
camembert dans lequel j'ai attribué les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre tout
gaz donc à la fois le co2 le méthane et
c'est un certain nombre de secteurs
d'activité
donc là la totalité des activités fait
100% de ce qu'on fait et je décompose ça
d'une façon que j'espère parente méthane
émis par les mines de charbon inclut
donc c'est vraiment une vue globale les
centrales à charbon représente
aujourd'hui dans le monde va pour cent
des émissions planétaires
dit autrement 1 une tonne équivalent co2
sur cinq ce qu'on appelle comme tous les
gaz sont ramenés au co2 avec le prg
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que tous les
autres gaz se comptent en équivalent co2
oui à 100 ans ça veut dire qu'une tonne
équivalent co2 sur cinq est mise dans le
monde vient d'une centrale à charbon ou
de sa chaîne d'approvisionnement
une sur cinq après vous avez des
centrales à gaz et à fuel
alors ça c'est essentiellement gaz qui
représente de l'ordre de 7% des
émissions planétaires en ce compris les
émissions de méthane qui sont
occasionnés par la chaîne gazière à
l'avant en rajoutant les combustibles
utilisés par les cimenteries la
production de ciment
ces six pour cent des émissions
planétaires retenez que les émissions
françaises ca et demi pour cent si vous
voulez avoir une base de comparaison
pour tout ce que je suis en train de
vous raconter
voilà ça vous donnera une petite idée le
reste de l'industrie
ces 12 alors là dedans c'est les
émissions directes
je n'ai pas compté les émissions de la
production électrique utilisée par
l'industrie
si je rajoute la production électrique
utilisée par l'industrie la part de
l'industrie passe de 12 à probablement
pour
cimenterie incluse pardon donc ça veut
dire passe de 18 à quelque chose qui se
balade aux alentours de entre 25 et 30
parce qu'une bonne partie de
l'électricité passe évidemment dans le
processus industriel donc là vous avez
12 dans lequel les aciéries représente à
peu près 4 sachant qu'à peu près la
moitié de l'acier produit dans le monde
sert à faire des bâtiments et des
infrastructures genre ton et c est que
la totalité du ciment sert à faire ça ça
veut dire que en gros construire des
bâtiments et des ponts sur terre c'est
un petit 10 % des émissions planétaires
donc là vous retrouvez aussi un élément
de croissance démographique s'il ya plus
de monde ont fait plus de bâtiments le
chauffage des bâtiments représentent 6%
des émissions alors vous allez dire
comment seulement 6% des émissions tout
à l'heure on a vu sur le graphique de la
france que etc
alors oui seulement 6% des émissions
pourquoi parce que une bonne partie des
bâtiments dans le monde n'ont pas besoin
d'être chauffé si vous avez un bâtiment
dans le sud de la californie
son problème c'est pas vraiment d'être
chauffé si vous avez un bâtiment à
singapour son problème c'est pas
vraiment d'être chauffé si vous avez un
bâtiment à lagos son problème c'est pas
vraiment d'être chauffé son problème par
contre et éventuellement les climatiser
et à ce moment les émissions de la
climatisation vous les avez pas la
petite chaudière voulais retrouver là et
là puisque c'est des émissions de la
production électrique mais sur le
chauffage direct
une bonne partie des bâtiments dans le
monde n'ont pas besoin ensuite là vous
avez du chauffage
enfin pardon en france vous n'avez pas
cette part la très importante parce
qu'on a très peu de choses de centrales
à charbon
vous avez une part ici qui est plus
faible parce qu'on a fini de construire
des infrastructures et on construit à un
rythme moins effréné que dans les pays à
forte croissance démographique
donc la part des cimenteries et plus
fait c'est donc par un effet de parts de
camembert plus petites à un certain
nombre d'endroits et bien les autres par
son corrélativement plus grosse mais
c'est juste pour montrer que les parts
peuvent varier beaucoup en fonction des
pays après cette très belle part aux
scellés transport alors dans les
transports la flotte mondiale de
voitures c'est aux alentours de 6 la
flotte mondiale de camions c'est aux
alentours
la flotte mondiale de bateaux alors en
jeu ici c'est peut-être cette mais c'est
en voilà la flotte mondiale de bateaux
et aux alentours de 2 et la flotte
mondiale d'avions est aux alentours de 2
aussi or gaz or co2 mais j'ai pas le
temps d'en parler pendant ce court donc
au t2 ce que vous voyez donc à ce stade
c'est que par exemple dans les usages de
type machine est bien le parc mondial de
cimenterie c'est le même problème que le
parc mondial de voitures
donc on n'est pas en train de parler
d'un truc totalement anecdotique le parc
mondial d'acier rice est le même que le
parc mondial de camions
ce que vous voyez également c'est que
les centrales à charbon c'est plus
important que la totalité des moyens de
transport dans le monde
si je regarde les émissions voilà donc
là vous commencez à avoir une base de
comparaison qui vous dit si j'ai envie
de m'occuper du problème
ou est-ce qu'il faut que je tape et vous
voyez que c'est pas juste
on va supprimer les voitures et on
s'arrête là ces problèmes est plus
compliqué que ça 20 % de nos émissions
c'est le fait de manger donc c'est
essentiellement des gaz or co2 donc là
dedans vous retrouvez les vaches le
reste du cheptel ruminants mais qui est
plus minoritaires les rizières
voilà les émissions et le protoxyde
d'azoté
deschamps est également de co2
détracteurs mais qui est totalement mine
inquiète a tellement minoritaires après
vous allez avoir la déforestation
alors la déforestation comme je disais
tout à l'heure est un processus amont de
l'activité agricole ce qui veut dire que
le fait de manger au sens large c'est
plutôt 30% des émissions planétaires et
enfin ici vous retrouvez des trucs
divers donc par exemple la gestion des
déchets dont par exemple les fuites de
chaîne du froid donc et c'est tout après
cole diverses diverses et variées voilà
ça c'est une manière de présenter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
voulait présenter la part grands
ensembles de
des missions directive en france
voilà à quoi ça ressemble alors envoyez
les par de camembert on retrouve les
mêmes part de camembert mais pas dû
d'abord pour présenter de la même
manière dont vous allez trouver le
transport qui arrive en tête
ensuite les bâtiments et l'agriculture
ensuite par henri bâtiment l'agriculture
et l'industrie à peu près à parité et
enfin le secteur énergétique lui il est
petit parce que encore une fois la
production électrique au charbon on en a
très peu et on c'est ça qui fait
l'essentiel de la différence
alors vous avez une autre manière de
présenter les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui sont les émissions qui sont
issus de notre empreinte carbone
alors notre empreinte carbone c'est quoi
c'est par opposition aux émissions qui
sont dites territoriales c'est à dire
les émissions qui viennent de la france
les émissions qui sont la contrepartie
de ce qu'on consomme quand vous regardez
les émissions présentées comme ça c'est
les émissions qui prennent place sur le
sol français
or les vêtements que vous portez
par exemple il y en a beaucoup qui ont
été made in ailleurs donc la fabrication
par exemple si vous portez comme je
voulais évoquer au poly folie cours des
fibres synthétiques
ces fibres synthétiques une partie des
émissions viennent d'ailleurs il a fallu
extraire du pétrole et il a fallu
commencer à craquer les molécules de
pétrole faire du plastique puis
transformé polymérisé les mots d'albert
puis etc enfin tout un tas de trucs une
partie n'a pas été fait en france
donc toutes les fibres polymachin
chouette les émissions ont pas été fait
en france
si vous achetez aujourd'hui un
ordinateur cet ordinateur n'a pas été
fait en france
donc les émissions de production de cet
ordinateur sont essentiellement des
émissions extra territoriale si vous
achetez des tomates espagnoles en cette
saison ce qui est très mal parce que ça
pompe les nappes phréatiques
peu importe à ce moment vous avez acheté
des tomates qui ont engendré des
émissions par exemple pour actionner les
pompes par exemple pour enrichir les
serres en co2 parce qu'ils se trouvent
il ya des serres qui sont enrichis en
co2 pour que les tomates poussent plus
donc on brûle le gaz enrichir les
séances et o2 tout ça n'a pas
nécessairement pris place en france etc
etc
donc en gros et puis si vous achetez une
voiture que un constructeur même
français a fabriqué en roumanie ou au
maroc
eh bien les émissions correspondantes
n'ont pas non plus pris place en france
donc dans la vision des émissions
territoriales
vous ne regardez que ce qui est fait en
france mais ça ne correspond pas
nécessairement à ce que vous vous allez
acheté ou consommé
ça ne correspond pas nécessairement à ça
ça correspond à ce qui s'est passé chez
nous et corrélativement une partie des
émissions qui se passe chez nous sont au
service de quelque chose qui va être
consommés à l'extérieur par exemple
quand vous fabriquez un airbus chez nous
et bien les émissions de fabrication de
l'airbus sont normalement dans une
vision consommation elles sont à imputer
à la compagnie aérienne qui va vous
achetez l'airbus qui est pas
nécessairement une compagnie française
et même essentiellement par les
compagnies françaises
quand vous faites du vin sont pas très
très riches en co2 la fabrication du vin
mais un peu quand même faut faire la
bouteille il faut la balade et en camion
etc
il faut faire passer des tracteurs et
bien cette bouteille de vin si elle est
exportée
ça c'est des émissions qui ont lieu en
france mais c'est pas vous qui allez
vous régaler en buvant la bouteille
corps donc les émissions territoriales
c'est les émissions de ce qui se passe
en france dans une vision consommation
on utilise quelque chose qui s'appelle
l'empreinte carbone que vous voyez ici
et qui elle correspond aux émissions qui
ont pris place pour que vous puissiez
bénéficier du produit ou du service que
vous allez utiliser encore les émissions
domestiques d'un français si je reprends
la courbe que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure celle qui est
pardon comme peuple si je reprends cette
courbe alors et vous divisez par la
population vous allez tomber sur le
chiffre de un peu moins de six tonnes de
co2 par français et par an juste pour le
co2 si vous y racheter si vous rajoutez
pardon les gaz
or co2 vous allez plutôt tombé sur huit
c'est 6 tonnes correspondent aux
émissions domestiques là sur la vision
que je vous propose de l'empreinte
carbone par français vous voyez que le
total fait plutôt discrète chose
11 donc on est au-dessus des 8 que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
la différence c'est quoi ces les
émissions qui ont pris place à
l'extérieur du pays et qui correspondent
aux biens de consommation qu'on a
importé pour pouvoir les consommer chez
nous donc la vertu climatique de la
france il ya évidemment une question qui
se pose c'est est-ce qu'elle s'apprécie
au regard de nos émissions territoriales
donc on dit chez nous on n'aimait pas
beaucoup ou est-ce qu'elle s'apprécie au
regard des émissions de la consommation
et à ce moment on devrait pouvoir dire
ce qu'on consomme chez nous ça et met
pas beaucoup et c'est un peu différent
oui alors l'empreinte carbone de la
chine en termes d'émissions domestique
est devenu ma nation de co2 est devenu
un peu supérieure à celle de la france
par contre comme vous le savez si vous
lisez les démêlés récent des chinois
avec monsieur trompe une partie de
l'empreinte carbone de la chine sert à
l'exportation donc en vision
consommation les chinois sont quand son
dos en vision territoriale
ils sont maintenant légèrement au dessus
des français en dessous des européens
encore là alors dans cette vision
territoriale je leur dis vous prenez les
émissions domestiques vous enlevez ce
qui sert l'exportation vous rajouter ce
qui sert l'importation en gros donc on
passe de 6 à 8 à 10 et alors ce que vous
voyez sur la décomposition de ce
graphique finalement c'est
d'où viennent à cas quels actes de la
vie courante sont associés les émissions
que nous avons aujourd'hui
et finalement ça pose la question de le
citoyen consommateur électeurs ou est-ce
qu'il va devoir faire des efforts seul
ou en association avec les gens qu'ils
ont fourni les produits ou services pour
que les émissions baisse
c'est ça la salle à la question alors
les émissions en france une première
partie vient du fait qu'ils ont
construit des logements
vous savez que chaque année on construit
des logements on en construit quelques
centaines de milliers alors évidemment
chaque personne ne se fait pas
construire un logement chaque année ça
marche peut être pour quelques délires
du pétrole mais français ordinaire ça
marche pas comme ça
par contre chaque année en france vous
avez quelques centaines de milliers de
logements qui sont construits et si
jeudi a rapporté aux français je regarde
ce que ça représente comme émission est
bien en gros ça représente quelques
centaines de kilos de co2 par français
et par an c'est à dire la construction
en raw de 1 à 1,5 mètre carré par
français et par an les émissions de
construction d'un logement
c'est quelques centaines de kilos de co2
par mètre carré selon ce que vous faites
en logement individuel en logements
collectifs etc
disons que ça se balade entre 200 et 400
donc voyez quand vous faites construire
une maison ou un appartement de 100
mètres carrés est bien assez d'un seul
coup d'un seul 20 à 40 tonnes de co2 qui
sans qu'ils parlent dans le poster ses
20 à 40 tonnes de co2 ça vient d'où de
l'acier qu'il faut fabriquer pour faire
les fers à béton du ciment qu'il faut
fabriquer pour faire le béton du
plastique qui va servir dans tout le
bâtiment les encadrements de fenêtres
les bâches que vous mettez parterre
l'étanchéité de la maison enfin du
l'appartement enfin vous avez du
plastique partout en bâtiment des tuiles
et des briques
enfin bref c'est donc un français une
année 1,5 mètre carré en ordre de
grandeur
après vous avez un deuxième élément qui
est le confort thermique et le confort
énergétique du logement confère ce que
je vous ai dit au moment du premier
cours bien qu'on dise que la france est
un pays tout nucléaire
nous utilisons quatre fois plus
d'énergie sous forme fossiles dans le
chauffage des bâtiments que d'énergie
électrique quatre fois plus donc une
bonne partie des émissions de co2 que
vous la faire de gaz à effet de serre
que vous avez l'air de penser
sincèrement du co2 que vous allez avoir
dans les logements vient du chauffage
avec le pays fait en utilisant du gaz et
du fioul
ça c'est la partie hors chauffage qui
pour le coup est purement électrique
alors en france nous avons un facteur
d'émission de l'électricité qui est très
bas même en tenant compte des
importations parce que de temps en temps
on importe un peu d'électricité
si nous étions en pologne ce petit
morceau là il ferait quelques à rien par
rapport à celui là sa double rsa
quadruples rsa sextuple le rsa
décuplerait l'aise
en gros ça hawks tu pleurais je sais pas
si ça existe ça serait multiplié par 8 à
10 donc cette barre là serait supérieure
à 7 bar là donc ça c'est un d une des
caractéristiques de la france qui comme
vous le savez a eu d'électricité qui est
peu carbonée si vous allez en suisse si
vous allez en suède
si vous allez en norvège vous allez
retrouver une proportion exactement une
importance de la consommation
d'électricité dans les logements dans
l'empreinte carbone globale qui va être
aussi raisonnablement faible par contre
si vous allez dans des pays dans
lesquels l'électricité carbonée et a
fortiori des pays dans lesquels en plus
du chauffage vous avez de la
climatisation typiquement vous allez
dans un climat continental au milieu des
états unis en crève de froid l'hiver en
crève de chaud l'été
là vous allez avoir et en plus leur
maison mal isolée
là vous allez avoir à la fois des
émissions de chauffage importante et les
émissions d'utilisation de l'électricité
très importante
potentiellement après vous avez une
barre ici qui s'appelle miam miam
alors ce que vous constatez c'est que
dans sur ce graphique
il ya d'autres analystes qui donne ça un
peu en dessous des biens de consommation
ont baissé les deux premiers postes qui
ressorte en gros ce qui va arriver en
premier dans l'empreinte carbone d'un
français c'est les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui sont la contrepartie
de ce que vous achetez à la fois en
biens courants et en biens durables là
dedans vous avez aussi dans les achats
vous avez aussi les machines à laver les
voitures etc et pour manger donc
l'alimentation et les achats c'est en
gros la moitié de l'empreinte carbone la
france est donc à chaque fois que vous
allez faire les soldes crack ya le
compteur à co2 qui se met en route à
chaque fois à chaque fois que vous allez
acheter une fringale un canapé joueurs
dès que vous rentrez dans un supermarché
que vous en ressortez avec autre chose
que ce qui se mange
il ya le compteur à c'est une brosse à
dents une balayette et toilettes que je
voulais il ya le compteur à co2 qui
s'est mis en route parce qu'il a fallu
fabriquer un de ces sanguine produit
puisque c'est à peu près ça qu'on a
maintenant dans les supermarchés et donc
comme je voulais expliquer au premier
cours la chaîne s'est mise en route
depuis l'extraction des matières
premières jusqu'à dire
livraison dans le supermarché pour que
ce produit ou ce service existe alors
dans l'alimentation à chaque fois dans
l'alimentation et dans l'est dans les
achats j'ai mis le premier constituant
dans chacun des cas de figure dans le
fret
il a pas été individualisées il n'a pas
été affecté au produit parce qu'à
l'époque on a fait cette analyse
44 on n'était pas capable d'imputer le
fret par catégories de marchandises
alors vous me direz on aurait pu faire
un truc au doigt mouillé qui est
j'aurais parti ça au prorata des valeurs
sauf qu'en fait le fret c'est au prorata
des tonnages les tonnages c'est pas
nécessairement les valeurs un camion qui
transporte des ordinateurs c'est pas la
même valeur qu'un camion qui transporte
des salades le contenu de la cargaison
donc on a on a eu du mal donc on n'a pas
imputé par contre ce que vous voyez ici
c'est que la première barre de
l'alimentation c'est la viande en
particulier la viande rouge et si je
rajoute les produits lactés qui sont un
autre dérivé du cheptel bovin et bien la
part des émissions qui vient en france 2
l'existence d'un cheptel bovin
c'est entre la moitié et les deux tiers
de notre empreinte carbone
oui
évidemment en fait c'est une analyse en
cycle de vie donc ce qu'on va compter
dans les émissions de la viande c'est
les émissions agricoles qui ont servi à
faire pousser les végétaux qui vont
permirent de nourrir l'animal
donc vous avez le diesel du tracteur
vous avez la fabrication des engrais
azotés qui vont être utilisés sur les
cultures végétales et cette fabrication
est fait en craquant du gaz là les
engrais azotés c'est la chimie de la
bonne yacks et la chimie de l'ammoniac
ça commence en produisant de l'hydrogène
en craquant du méthane j'ai autant de
co2 qu'on veut je suis reprendre la
question pardon et après je vous avais
les émissions de n2o en provenance des
champs
vous allez avoir sa également puisque
s'il a fallu que ces émissions aient
lieu pour avoir les végétaux puis vous
avez les émissions du métabolisme de la
vache d'accord ah oui tout ça mis bout à
bout et en fait c'est tout ça a mis
bout-à-bout qui vous fait l'empreinte
carbone de la viande dans la barre que
vous avez là et c'est pareil pour les
fromages dont pour récupérer après c'est
une affaire d'imputation c'est à dire
que le cheptel bovin il vous produits de
la viande du lait et du fromage sert du
lait transformés et il ya une question
de savoir comment on alloue ça alors
c'est on peut en discuter pendant des
heures est-ce qu'on alloue sa
économiquement est-ce qu'on alloue
sympathiquement en sachant qu'une une
vache laitière elle vous fait des tonnes
de lait par an pendant quelques années
et à la fin il vaudrait 500 kg de
carcasse
alors est ce que la viande est à déchets
en ce moment ça vaut zéro est ce que la
viande c'est ce que vous payez cher donc
ça vaut pas du tout 0 est ce que vous
voilà donc il ya tout un tas de mais
c'est sale c'est ça le principe dans le
diagramme que je vous montre on compte
tout ce qui a été nécessaire de début
jusqu'à la fin
ah pardon il y avait une question là et
après au fond
attention ne confondez pas de choses là
vous êtes en jeu que je compte c'est pas
des émissions de co2 du carbone contenu
dans les végétaux c'est les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre or carbone contenu
dans les végétaux qui sont nécessaires
pour que les végétaux pousse donc pour
les végétaux pousse des tracteurs qui
passe ça ça brûle du diesel
enfin du soul ça c'est pas de carbone
des végétaux vous épandez des engrais
dans les champs c'est dû être 2 o c pas
le carbone des végétaux et ça va pas je
suis pas le compter une deuxième fois
parce que la vache quand elle rumine
c'est pas équivalent à passer un
tracteur dans le champ et s'est pas non
plus équivalent à épandre des engrais
par terre donc c'est toute la chaîne
il y avait une question au fond oui
c'est une assez ce que des valeurs c'est
une affaire d'allocations en gros pour
faire un kilo de fromage type compte est
excellent que je vous recommande
il faut 10 litres de lait donc le
contenu carbone par kilo du comté en
gros est dix fois supérieur au contenu
carbone par kilo du lait est ce que je
vous ai montré ses terres à porter à
l'unité de masse j'aurais pu prendre une
autre échelle j'aurais pu rapporter à la
calorie j'aurais pu rapporter à l'euro
il ya toujours une convention dans cette
histoire là je vous ai proposé par kilo
la calorie et problème en plus
pertinents si vous voulez vraiment
commencé à faire des comparaisons entre
aliments le pardon juste pour finir la
dernière fois après le fait que vous
ayez temps pour le lait est temps pour
la viande
je le redis c'est une france et une
convention si vous regardez les races
laitières les races laitières vous les
utilisez essentiellement co produire du
lait donc vous pouvez dire que en gros
la carcasse de la vache en fin de vie
c'est un déchet d'ailleurs ça vous
feriez du lait même si personne vous
achetez la carcasse donc vous pouvez
dans une analyse de cycle de vie quand
vous avez un déchet que vous valorisez
vous confesser à 0 si vous dites que ça
a quand même un peu de valeur
vous pouvez compter ça au prorata de la
basse mais comme encore une fois via les
30 tonnes de lait qui ont été produits
par la vache sur sa durée de vie versus
500 kg de carcasse à l'arrivée oui ça
vous fait pas
émission qui sont affectés à la viande
si vous prenez
si vous agrégé ensemble les vaches
laitières en fin de vie et les races à
viande qui ne sont faites que pour la
viande
vous allez avoir une valeur moyenne pour
votre contenu carbone par kilo de viande
qui est beaucoup plus élevé donc ça
dépend vraiment de la manière dont vous
faites votre calcul par contre ce qui
est intéressant cela ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on n'a pas
discriminer ces terres je prends les
émissions de l'ensemble du cheptel bovin
et je dis ça ça va dans la viande
oui alors le nucléaire on a un chapitre
là dessus donc je vous en parlerai à ce
moment là là je suis juste en train
d'essayer de vous faire réfléchir sur
les émissions et moi dit autrement là
dedans
qu'est-ce qui est arbitrable par le
consommateur enfin on va pas en discuter
longuement aujourd'hui 17 prépare cette
réflexion
qu'est-ce qui est arbitrable par le
consommateur c'est hier qu'est ce qui
relève de mon libre arbitre et je décide
ou pas de faire ça qu'est ce qui est
déjà un peu plus compliqué parce que ça
relève de la manière dont la société
s'est organisée dans un contexte dans
lequel on va vous d'erevan demandé mon
avis donc ce que vous voyez
pour finir donc l'alimentation c'est le
premier poste c'est important geste
insisté là dessus parce que pendant très
très longtemps et encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup on présente souvent la question
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique comme un problème
d'abord or climat c'est à dire des
éoliennes et panneaux solaires et quand
on rentre dans le climat de transport
on va beaucoup se focaliser sur les
transports à ce que je demande c'est que
les deux premiers postes vue du
consommateur final sont pas là et donc
ici vous avez ce que vous achetez petit
quizz quelle était la hauteur de cette
barre en 1990
et bien en 1990 la barre faisait la
hauteur de sa plus ça dit autrement ce
qui s'est passé entre 1990 et 2010 c'est
que les émissions qui sont la
contrepartie de ce qu'on achetait avant
l'électronique les chemises les tables
et canapés les lunettes etc est resté à
peu près la même et on a rajouté à sa
les émissions de fabrication
d'électronique et les émissions de
fabrication de l'électronique
alors j'ai pas prévu de slide là-dessus
mais je le mettrais peut-être dans le
diaporama que je que je laisserai un
testament
retenez que les émissions de fabrication
aujourd'hui les émissions du système
numérique mondiale c'est-à-dire la
production annuelle des ordinateurs de
toute nature que ce soit les serveurs
les ordinateurs que je suis en train
d'utiliser vos smartphones qui sont en
fait des ordinateurs déjà beaucoup plus
puissant que le premier ordinateur dont
je parlais tout à l'heure qui était fait
dans les années 50 la leygnac et les
éléments de réseaux qui sont nécessaires
pour que ça communique et les data
center et l'électricité qui est
nécessaire tous les ans pour alimenter
tout ça donc à la fois la production
annuelle de tous ses composants et
l'électricité qui alimente tout ça tous
les ans et bien l'ensemble des émissions
qui sont la contrepartie de tout ça
chaque année c'est déjà 4 % des
émissions planétaires c'est à dire la
même chose que la flotte mondiale de
camions et ça augmente de 10 % tous les
ans quasiment donc si vous voulez un
truc pas durable le numérique
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on fait de plus
emblématiques dans le pas durable l'idée
qu'on a dématérialisé en mettant du
numérique partout malheureusement c'est
l'exact inverse ce qu'on est en train de
faire ce compartiment là il n'existait
pas il ya 20 ans et croyez le ou pas je
suis né dans un monde dans lequel il n'y
avait pas de smartphone ça existe et ça
a existé
il n'y avait pas d'ordinateur portable
voilà il n'y avait même pas de téléphone
portable
ici vous avez la contrepartie des
déplacements individuels
donc là dans les déplacements
professionnels sont pas pris en compte
donc si par exemple vous avez un
conférencier qui vient des états unis
pour vous faire une conférence dans
cette école en avion c'est peu probable
qu'il le fasse en kayak de mer
eh bien ça ne sera pas dans l'empreinte
carbone de l'américain en question parce
que c'est un déplacement professionnel
donc là vous n'avez que le déplacement
personnel
ce que vous voyez c'est que l'essentiel
c'est la voiture mais là vous avez un
gros paquet qui est essentiellement
l'avion et l'avion ça c'est pareil en
1990 ce truc n'existait à peu près pas
quand j'avais votre âge pardon de faire
le vieux schnock mais je suis parti en
stage aux états unis nous étions donc en
1986 et bien en 1986 partir en avion aux
etats-unis s'était passé la nuit à orly
pour prendre à chartered on vous saviez
pas à quelle heure il est vraiment
partir et puis c'était l'aventuré votre
vie vous arrivé là bas 10 heures à
l'avancé et c'est au fond c'est ça une
fois l'impression d'avoir fait un
exploit et c'était à l'époque encore
plus qu'aujourd'hui
réservé aux csp + fussent et c'est donc
l'avion est un truc qui a explosé sur
les 15 dernières années
et soit dit en passant ses émissions là
ne sont pas dans les inventaires
nationaux
parce que quand un avion d'air france
quitte un aéroport allemand pour aller
aux états unis avec un passager indien
eh bien personne ne veut des émissions
les français disent ah bah non c'est à
transporter un passager qui est pas de
chez moi pour aller de l'allemagne aux
états unis donc ça peut pas être pas
être moi même si air france s'apprête à
moi l'allemagne va dire ça peut pas être
à moi s'il allait aux états unis les
etats unis se disent ah peut pas être à
voir parce qu'il transportait l'indien
et l'indien dit ça peut pas être à moi
puisque je prenais un avion français
donc le résultat des courses c'est que
ces trucs là ne sont pas personne ça
n'est dans aucun inventaire national et
ça se retrouve dans un truc qui
s'appelle les soutes
dans ce cas ci on vous voyez dans les
dents les diagrammes des missions là un
truc s'appelle soute
et bien en fait c'est les émissions dont
personne ne veut parce que ça a pris
place dans l'espace international
alors si ses soutes aérienne c'est un
avion
français transportant un indien de
allemagne à en bretagne et si ses soutes
maritime et ben c'est pareil c'est un
cargo enfin ou un porte-conteneurs de
mer ce qu on pas dit danoise qui est
parti de anvers pour rallier shanghai en
transportant des trucs fait encore et
voilà c'est pareil à ce moment tout le
monde dit les émissions c'est pas à moi
oui c'est pas cher c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué la dernière fois en fait
rapporté en minutes de temps de travail
le prix du billet d'avion a été divisé
par 10 donc voilà pourquoi vous emmerder
la vie quand il jette vous offre un truc
à bratislava pour 40 euros
vous faites oui le train est infinie est
imperceptible le train en france c'est
en gros 2 % en ordre de grandeur de
l'énergie utilisée par les transports
aérien et routier
et en plus c'est décarbonée donc c'est
pas visible là c'est l'épaisseur du
times c'est c'est moins de l'épaisseur
du trait j'ai alors les chiffres en
france le transport aérien domestique
parce que c'est en fait il faut comparer
des trucs comparables le transport
aérien domestique
ces quelques millions de passagers par
an par et toulouse ces 2,5 après 5,5 sur
1000 km en ordre de grandeur
donc 5 millions promis ça vous fait 5
milliards de passagers kilomètres le
train c'est beaucoup plus important
c'est de l'or de 70 donc ce que vous
voyez
pardon donc la barre en 1990 elle était
autres comme ça et ça ça sert à sauter
et enfin ici vous avez les services
publics alors pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez des émissions varient service
public très mauvaise nouvelle pour vous
à chaque fois que vous rentrez dans cet
amphi vous émettez des gaz à effet de
serre parce que il faut l'hiver chauffer
l'envié leur prend cette saison parce
qu'il a fallu construire cette école ya
longtemps cela étant maintenant il ya
prescription
parce qu'il faut que je vienne ici et
tous les autres profs comme moi et c'est
donc l'éducation nationale occasionne
des émissions
l'éducation nationale emploie quasiment
un million de personnes n'ont pas de
quasiment une personne de l'ordre du
million de personnes
elle chauffe énormément bâtiment il ya
énormément de bâtiments de l'éducation
enfin de lait des lycées des écoles etc
qui sont chauffés donc c'est des
émissions deuxième gros postes
d'émissions la santé la santé occasionne
probablement de l'ordre de 5 % de
l'empreinte carbone du pays parce qu'il
faut chauffer les hôpitaux fabriquer les
médicaments fabriqués les scanner
fabriquer les consommables fabriquer les
appareils qui servent à savoir si vous
avez choper une maladie honteuse ou pas
et c'est donc tout ça c'est des choses
qui vont concourir à l'empreinte carbone
de l'hôpital et enfin le dernier grand
postes dans les services publics
auxquels vous allez sûrement pas pensé
cei c'est bien normes et pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont vu top gun vous
vous rappelez que l'armée c'est des gros
objets qui consomment beaucoup beaucoup
de kérosène ou de carburant la
consommation de pétrole de l'armée
américaine c'est entre le tiers et la
moitié de la consommation de pétrole de
la france
or donc en france devant plus petite
armée
ça représente quand même quelques et
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
vous appartient à vous tous dans votre
empreinte carbone puisque vous êtes tous
entre guillemets bénéficiaires du fait
qu' on est un système de soins un
système d'enseignement ou une ans donc
ça c'était la partie changement
climatique sur ce qu'est ce que c'est
que le climat que sont les émissions et
la prochaine fois on verra ce que ça
fait au système climatique et ce en sont
les conséquences
voilà